التّحول الرّقمي والخدمات الرّقمية
والحكومة الرّقمية هي وسيلة دائمًا
إذا أصبحت غاية فنحن في المسار الخطأ
اليوم نحن ذكرنا عشرين مليار
تصرفها الحكومة على قطاع الاتصالات
وتقنية المعلومات
طيب كم من العشرين مليار هذا مستورد؟ 68%
أوصف لي أنه منصّة وحدة هدخل
رحلتي كباحث عن عمل من أول ما أتخرج
إلى أن أحصل على الدعم
إلى أن أحصل على التدريب
إلى أن أقدّم على الوظائف
إلى أن أربط بالتأمينات الاجتماعية
هذه كلها في منصّة وحدة ولا شيء صار من هذه
هذا سقراط من إذاعة ثمانية
وأنا عمر الجريسي أستضيف قادة التّحول
وقادة الأعمال
وقادة الرأي
أتذكر مرّة وصلني سؤال على
لو خلصوا ضيوف سقراط بتوقف سقراط؟
فكان الجواب أنه أكيد سقراط هيوقف يوم من الأيام
بس لن يكون السبب نقص الضيوف
أو انعدام الضيوف
فنحن عندنا قصة تحولية متجددة
وكل مرة نلاقي
سبب لاستضافة ضيوف جدد
وأحيانًا نفس الضيف يكون
فرصة لاستضافته بعد فترة أو بقبّعة أخرى
زي ما هو حاصل مع ضيفنا اليوم
معالي المهندس أحمد الصويان
اللّي استضفناه سابقًا بصفته وكيل وزارة الماليّة
وتحدث عن تجربة اعتماد
اليوم نستضيفه بصفته محافظ
هيئة الحكومة الرّقمية ليحدثنا عن فكرة هذه الهيئة
أيش دورها؟
وأيش موقعها في المنظومة
بجوار بقية الهيئات اللّي لها علاقة بقطاع التقنية؟
تكلمنا على أبرز التحديات
موضوع احتكار الشركات الحكومية للبيانات وللخدمات الحكومية
على موضوع تعدد المنصّات وإرهاق المستفيد
من التنقل بين هذه المنصّات
على أحيانًا تنافس بعض التطبيقات الحكومية
على نفس الموضوع
سولفنا عن ترتيبنا في المؤشرات الدولية
سولفنا عن أهم الحالات اللي تعتبر قصص نجاح حكومية جميلة
في التّحول الرّقمي
وسولفنا عن أبرز التحديات وكيف يتم التعامل معها
وأخيرًا تكلمنا عن مستقبل الحكومة الرّقمية
كيف شكل الخدمات الحكومية الرّقمية في عام 2030
هذه بعض محاور حلقتنا اليوم
أترككم مع الحوار
حيّاك الله أبو صِبا شرفتنا ونورتنا
أهلًا وسهلًا يسعدني جدًّا
الله يحييك
نحن أبو صِبا الحلقة الماضية الي كانت في سبتمبر 2020
كنا نسولف على موضوع تحدي إدارة الوقت
وتوزيع الوقت على المسؤوليات الأسرية والاجتماعية
والعمل في منظومة عمل مرّة متطلبة
زي اللّي قاعد يصير الآن في الرؤية
حتى آخر مشية مشيناها في حي السفارات
كان نفس النقاش
فرق شيء؟
حلّيتوا المشكلة ولا ما زالت مشكلة؟
والله هالوقت ما تغيّر إلى الآن أربعة وعشرين ساعة
فالمشكلة قائمة
القائمة والمهام تزيد
ولكن بلا شك وجود فريق متميز
يتم الاعتماد عليه بشكل كبير
هو الحقيقة اللّي ممكن أنه نعوّل عليه
أنه يفوّض كثير من الأعمال
بلا شك إدارة الوقت مهمة جدًّا
وضع خطط واضحة سواءً قصيرة المدى
أو متوسطة المدى أو على المستوى الاستراتيجي مهم جدًّا
حتى إنك تنظم وقتك ما بين العمل وما بين البيت
وسألت أنا مهند قبل شوي أسولف معه
قلت له: متى الفترة اللّي ما يجيكم أيّ اتصال من أبو صِبا؟
قال لي: المغرب
عفوًا، قال: يوم الجمعة من بعد الصلاة إلى المغرب
هذه الفترة الي ما يجينا شيء
عدا هذه الفترة أنتم طوال الأسبوع شغّالين
وأيش سر هالفترة؟ وأيش قاعدين تسوون فيها؟
لإني أصير عند الوالد
عند الوالد!
هذه الفترة فترة مهمة جدًّا
أحرص أنه أكون عند الوالد والوالدة
و أحرص إني ما أزعج زملائي
على الأقل يوم الجمعة بهالفترة
ما بين الصلاة إلى تقريبًا الفترة المسائية
وأنا مقدّر جهودهم ويتحملوني كثير
طلباتي لا تنتهي وملاحظاتي كثيرة
لكن زملائي جزاهم الله خير
بالهم وسيع ويتحمّلوني جدًّا
وأنا فخور فيهم، اليوم ما تحقّق في الحكومة الرّقمية
وأيضًا زملائي في الجهات الحكومية
أنا فريقي بالمناسبة ليس فقط
فريقي في هيئة الحكومة الرّقمية
كل مسؤول ومبرمج
ومن يعمل على إدارة الجودة أو التصميم
في أي إدارة تقنية معلومات في أي جهة حكومية
يعتبر امتداد لفريقي وكل لي شكر وامتنان
لما يقدّمون لكل المستفيدين
سواءً مواطنين أو شركات
أو حتى الخدمات الحكومية الداخلية
نحن أبو صِبا سعداء باستضافتك اليوم بصفتك
محافظ الهيئة الحكومة الرّقمية
الهيئة التي تأسّست في 2021
ومن تلك الفترة وأنت تقودها
خلينا نبدأ ونحكي أيش حكومة رقميّة؟
ومن متى السعودية فيها خدمات رقميّة حكومية؟
طبعًا القصة بدأت من فترة طويلة
يمكن من عام 1980
أو قبل ذلك لما بدأت اللبنة الأولى
بمركز المعلومات الوطني
لما كان إدارة داخل وزارة الداخلية
ومن ذلك الحين ونحن ولله الحمد
في استمرار بعملية تطوير شاملة
ولكن الخمسة سنوات الأخيرة وتحديدًا
مع انطلاق برامج تحقيق الرؤية كان في فرق كبير جدًّا
في الخدمات المقدمة للمستفيدين في كل القطاعات
ولكن في البداية أظن من المهم جدًّا
أنه نعرّف الحكومة الرّقمية
وقبل الحكومة الرّقمية خليني أعرّف مفهوم جديد
اللّي هو الاقتصاد الرّقمي اللّي الحكومة الرّقمية جزء منه
اليوم نلاحظ في كل جوانب الحياة
أنه القطاعات بدأ يكون بينها جزء من التداخل
لما تشوف القطاع المصرفي مع قطاع الاتصالات
مع قطاع التأمين
مع القطاع التجاري أو قطاع البيع بالتجزئة
نجد أنه في بينها تقارب كبير
فاليوم أصبح عندنا مفهوم جديد اسمه الاقتصاد الرّقمي
والاقتصاد الرّقمي بكل بساطة لما أحاول أعرفه
هو مستوى مختلف تمامًا عن البنية التحتية التقليدية
أو ما يسمى الاتصالات وتقنية المعلومات
وخلينا نعطي رقم عمر يمكن عشان يوضّح الفرق
البنية التحتية التقليدية
الاتصالات وتقنية المعلومات اللّي هي خدمات الاتصالات
الخدمات التقنية العادية
هذه لا تمثل سوى 4% تقريبًا
من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي
ولكن الاقتصاد الرّقمي يصل إلى 14%
وهذا بالنسبة لنا يمثّل فرصة
طيب أيشش الفرق بين البنية التحتية
خدمات الاتصالات وتقنية المعلومات
والاقتصاد الرّقمي؟ بكل بساطة كيف نستطيع
خلق نسيج رقمي موحّد ما بين السّعات والطلب
السّعة اللّي تقدمها خدمات الاتصالات
والخدمات التقنية بشكلها الواسع
والطلب اللّي يجي من القطاعات، كل القطاعات
سواءً قطاع التعليم
قطاع الصحة
قطاع البلديات أو غيره
وفي تعريف آخر قد يكون أكثر تحديدًا وأكثر دقّة
وزّع على ثلاثة مستويات رئيسية
المستوى الأول
هو المستوى المعروف اللّي يسمى الأساس أو البنية التحية
وهذه الخدمات التقليدية اللّي نحن نقول 4%
مثل إيش؟
مثل خدمات الاتصالات
4 جي و5 جي وخدمات الفايبر
خدمات التقنية الأساسية
هذه البنية التحتية وتمثل 4%
بالضّبط هذه 4% وهذه اللّي عشنا عليها يمكن عشرين
أو ثلاثين سنة ماضية
وفي مستوى جديد
بدأ خلال يمكن السنوات الماضية
خلينا نقول من عشرة سنوات أقل أو أكثر
اللّي هو المستوى اللّي يسمى بالناروت أو المحدد
إيش هو هذا؟
هذه الأعمال التي تعتمد بشكل كامل على
خدمات الاتصالات وتحديدًا خدمات الانترنت
خلني أبسطها، إذا الانترنت توقف
توقفت هذه الأعمال ولو نأخذ عليها نماذج بسيطة
على مستوى العالم عندنا أوبر
عندنا إير بي أم بي
وعندنا أيضًا في السعودية على سبيل المثال جاهز
وأيضًا إس تي دي سي باي
فهذا مستوى جدًّا مهم
يربط ما بين الساعات خدمات الاتصالات وقطاعات الأعمال
و في مستوى ثالث اللّي هو المستوى الواسع أو الشامل
يسمى بروت وهذا طبعًا كل
القطاعات أو الأعمال اللّي بلا شك تستفيد من التقنية
كجهاز داعم أو كخدمات ممكّنة
ولكن ليس بالضرورة تتوقف أعمالها عند عدم توفرها
وهذا بطبيعة الحال أي شركة
مثلًا تعمل سواءً في البنوك
أو تعمل على سبيل المثال في قطاع الغاز
البتروكيماويات أو غيرها
مثل إنه يكون عنده نظام إدارة موارد مؤسّسية
أو نظام إدارة علاقات عملاء أو غيره
هذه المستويات الثّلاثة
الحكومة الرّقمية، وين موقعكم أنتم؟
الحكومة الرّقمية يقع بين العرض والطلب
هو في كثير من الأحيان يقدّم سعات
وأيضًا يطلب، هو يطلب من الخدمات الاتصالات
وأيضًا يوفّر خدمات للقطاعات كلها
سواءً كانت القطاع الصحي أو القطاع التعليمي أو خلافه
ولو نربطها بحلقة أيضًا سابقة مع رئيس برنامج يسّر
كان في برنامج اسمه برنامج يسّر
للتعاملات الحكومية الإلكترونية
هل أنتم برنامج يسّر بس أكشخ؟
بقبعة وكرافته أو في شيء مختلف في مفهوم
الحكومة الرّقمية عن برنامج يسّر للتعاملات الإلكترونية؟
بلا شك برنامج يسّر بالفترة يمكن ما بين 2005 - 2006
إلى تقريبًا 2020 كان له دور مهم جدًّا
نحن امتداد لعملية التّحول مثلما ذكرت لك من عام 1980
والعمل مستمر في التطوير
الوضع مختلف
هو مختلف إلى حدٍ ما بشكل كبير
عن برنامج يسّر وخلني أقول
شلون؟
الاختلافات الرئيسية
هيئة الحكومة الرّقمية دورها الأساسي
هو دور تنظيم وإشراف
لا تدخل في الجانب التشغيلي أبدًا
يسّر كان يدخل في الجانب التشغيلي؟
بلا شك، يسّر كان عنده دور تشغيلي لمجموعة من المنتجات
اللّي تخدم الجهات الحكومية
بينما هيئة الحكومة الرّقمية دورها تنظيم
وفي السعودية عندنا ثلاثة أنواع من التشغيل
للخدمات الحكومية الرّقمية
النوع الأول: أنه الجهة الحكومية تقوم باستضافة
وتطوير وتشغيل الخدمات بنفسها
عندها إدارة تقنة معلومات وهي التي تشغل
النوع الثّاني
مثل؟ ممكن أخذ مثال على آخر وحدة؟
الأمثلة كثيرة على سبيل المثال وزارة الصحة
الشؤون البلدية والقروية والإسكان
في وكالة أو إدارة خاصة بتقنية المعلومات
وتقوم بتوفير الخدمات بشكل كامل
هذا النّموذج الأول
النّموذج الثّاني: أنه جهة حكومية أخرى
تقوم بتطوير وتشغيل الخدمات بالنيابة عن الجهة الحكومية
مثلًا؟
نحن عندنا في السعودية عدد من الجهات الحكومية
يساهمون في تطوير وتشغيل المنصّات
أبرز مثال الهيئة السعودية للبيانات والذكاء الاصطناعي
الزملاء في سدايا
وهي بالمناسبة المحرك الرئيسي
للكثير من الخدمات الحكومية الرّقمية
وأيضًا الزملاء في المركز الوطني لنظم الموارد الحكومية
وهم دورهم مهم جدًّا في الجانب الذي يتعلق بالموارد الحكومية
نأخذ مثال ممكن على منصّة محدّدة مثلًا
على سبيل المثال منصّة اعتماد
المالك لها وزارة الماليّة
المشغل إن سي جي آر، المركز الوطني لنظم الموارد الحكومية
منصّة أبشر، المالك لها وزارة الداخلية والمشغل سدايا
وهذه الفكرة بشكل عام
والنّوع الثّالث اللّي هو
هذا النّموذج الثّاني
النّموذج الثّالث: اللّي هي لما تكون شركة
تقوم بتقديم الخدمات بالنيابة عن الجهة الحكومية
وفقًا لنموذج تعاقدي معيّن
وهذا أيضًا طبعًا الأمثلة فيه كثيرة
وطبعًا بلا شك أنه دور الشركات مهم جدًّا
ويعطينا قيمة سواءً كانت شركة علم
شركة ثقة
شركة تكامل
شركة تحكّم، والكثير من الشركات اللّي فخورين
جدًّا بالدور اللّي تقدمه، فأيضًا هذا نموذج ثالث للتشغيل
وهذه النماذج الثّلاثة هي المفترض هيئة الحكومة الرّقمية
تشرف عليها وتنظمها وهذا الملعب حقكم ولا لا؟
بالضّبط اي نعم، هذا الدور وخلّينا نرجع للتعريف
أيش هو؟ الحكومة الرّقمية خلينا نعرّفها
التعريفات طبعًا كثيرة
يمكن أبرزها تعريف الأو إي سي دي
اللّي هي منظمة التعاون الاقتصادي والتنمية
أيش يقولون؟
باختصار الاستفادة من التقنية كجزء أساسي
من أعمال الحكومات أو استراتيجياتها
لتقديم أيش؟ لتقديم قيمة
وقيمة هنا
شاهد مهم جدًّا لكثير من الجوانب
ولكن أنا ببسّط التعريف خليني أقولها بلغة أسهل
الحكومة الرّقمية ثلاثة مكوّنات
و ثلاثة مستهدفات، أيش هي المكوّنات؟
المكوّنات: تنظيمات
لازم يكون عندك تنظيم
الثّاني: خدمات رقميّة بطبيعة الحال تبغى حكومة رقميّة
لازم يكون عندك خدمات رقميّة
والمكوّن الثّالث: اللّي هو هام جدًّا إدارة التّغيير
لازم يكون عندك مسار خاص لإدارة التّغيير
أيش الأهداف؟
الأهداف لازم إنك يكون عندك إنتاجية أفضل
لازم يكون عندك كفاءة أعلى
ولازم تحسّن من التجربة
لأن كفاءة وإنتاجية وتجربة، هذه الأهداف
أحسّها كلها واضحة وحلوة
الثّالثة موضوع إدارة التّغيير هي اللي
ودّي لو تسولفنا فيها أكثر، لأنها شوية مثيرة
إدارة التّغيير هي الأهم، من السهل جدًّا
إنك تسوي تنظيمات
تحط سياسات
تحط معايير
تحط ضوابط
من السهل
إنك تطور خدمات ولا حتى تشتري منتجات تقنية
وتقول: هذه المنتجات التقنية ممكن إني أقدمها
إدارة التّغيير أساس لكل نجاح
إدارة التّغيير إذا ما كان عندك تدريب واضح
وتواصل مع ملّاك الأعمال والمستفيدين
وكل الشرائح اللّي أنت تحتاج إنك تتأكد إنهم يدخلون معك
ستواجه مقاومة، وراح يكون عندك تحدي كبير جدًّا
هذا من جانب عمر
في جانب ثاني مهم جدًّا دائمًا ليس فقط في الحكومة
ولكن أيضًا في القطاع الخاص ممكن أن نقع فيه
أنه يتحوّل
التّحول الرّقمي أو الخدمات التقنية هدف بذاته
متى ما تحوّل الخدمات الرّقمية أو التّحول الرّقمي
إني أنا والله هدفي إني أسوي تحوّل رقمي
إذن أنا في المسار الخطأ
التّحول الرّقمي والخدمات الرّقمية والحكومة الرّقمية
هي وسيلة دائمًا إذا أصبحت غاية فنحن في المسار الخطأ
الهدف لازم يكون عندك إنتاجية
لازم يكون عندك كفاءة
ولازم يكون عندك تجربة أفضل
بعض الأحيان نجد تنافس أنه والله نحن نبغى نوقّف ورق
نجد تنافس أنه لا والله أنا لازم أشتري تقنية معينة
أو لازم أطور تقنية معينة
يجب أن يكون عندك مركزية مستفيد واضحة
أن تبدأ من المستفيد واحتياجات المستفيد
وقطاعات الأعمال، وبعدين تشوف الحلول المطلوبة
حتى إنك تصنع القيمة وتقدمها بشكل واضح
ما زلنا نحاول نتعرف على الهيئة ونفهم دورها
وبعدها ندخل على أهم ما تحقّق
فيمكن آخر سؤال عندي في هذا الجانب
أبغى أفهم المنظومة
الفترة الماضية كثير هيئات لها علاقة بقطاع
تقنية المعلومات أو قطاع التقنية بشكل عام
تأسّست وما صرنا عارفين ما هي الحدود الفاصلة
فعندنا هيئة الأمن السيبراني
عندنا هيئة البيانات والذكاء الاصطناعي سدايا
عندنا هيئة الحكومة الرّقمية
عندنا هيئة الاتصالات وتقنية المعلومات
عندنا وزارة الاتصالات وتقنية المعلومات
عندنا هيئة الفضاء الآن دمجت معهم بشكل أو بآخر
ودّي أفهم بشكل مبسّط
أيش دور هؤلاء اللاعبين المختلفين؟
وليش عندنا هذا العدد الكبير نسبيًا
أو من وجهة نظري في الهيئات المنظمة؟
ممتاز، أنا في البداية
يمكن خليني أتكلم عن منظومة الاتصالات وتقنية المعلومات
أتذكر آسف لو قاطعتك معالي السواحة في
مؤتمر ميزانية رسمها بشكل حلو
رسم ثلاثة دوائر
دائرة الابتكار
ودائرة تقنية المعلومات
ودائرة الفضاء
وفي النص كانت تقاطعاتهم كلهم الاقتصاد الرّقمي
هذه الثّلاثة المناطق اللّي هو مسؤول عنها أو لا؟
ثلاثة فروع رئيسية: الاقتصاد الرّقمي
الابتكار
والفضاء
هذه الفروع الرئيسية أو المسارات الرئيسية اللّي نعمل عليها
وبالمناسبة خلني أتكلم عن المنظومة
المنظومة العمل فيها يمثّل شرفة على المستقبل
دائمًا كلنا حماس، خلية نحل لا تنام
دائمًا عندنا هدف نحقّقه بشكل سريع جدًّا وبجودة عالية
لا يهم المستوى
ولا يهم الجانب الإداري نحط هدف ونستطيع تحقيقه
وعندنا ثقافة مختلفة بشكل كبير
بيئة تشجّع على البحث والتجربة
نسمح بارتكاب الأخطاء الجديدة
ولذلك ما عندنا والله هذا في الجهة الفلانية
خلاص هذا اختصاصه
أو هذا والله في المكان الفلاني هذا اختصاصه
عندنا هدف ويمكن أحد النماذج اللّي عُمل في مؤتمر ليب
يمكن المؤتمر التقني الأكبر
على مستوى العالم كلنا نعمل كفريق واحد بهذا الاتجاه
وهي ثلاثة مسارات كما ذكرت
الابتكار والفضاء والاقتصاد الرّقمي
بالابتكار شاهدنا إعلان سمو سيّدي وليّ العهد الله يحفظه
اللّي هي الأولويات الوطنية البحث والتطوير والابتكار
وشفنا إطلاق الكراج اللّي اليوم فيه
شركات الناشئة ليس فقط سعودية، ولكن من حول العالم
وأيضًا الفضاء
يمكن هاليومين شفنا الرحلة
التاريخية الحقيقة لريّانة برناوي وعلي القرني
اللي الحمدلله وصلوا بالسلامة من محطة الفضاء الدولية
وأنا أتمنى أن يكون في فرصة لأصحاب المعالي
الدكتور منير الدسوقي أبو عمر وأيضًا
عاونّا عليهم تكفى
أكيد، وأيضًا أبو فارس
هم ما يقصرون بس لسى ما بعد حصلنا على الموعد
بالعكس، أنا أعتقد الابتكار والفضاء فيها فرص كبيرة
وفيها تفاصيل كثيرة هم أفضل من يتحدّث عنها
ولكن أرجع للاقتصاد الرّقمي والجهات اللي في المنظومة
يمكن في ثلاثة مستويات
صانع السياسات
والمنظم القطاعي
والمشغل
وفي جانب آخر ما بين الوطني والقطاعي
اليوم صانع السياسات هي وزارة الاتصالات
وتقنية المعلومات، ما في شك أنه صانع هذا السوق
وفي منظّمين قطاعيين
على سبيل المثال هيئة الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنية
هي مسؤولة عن السّعات
هي مسؤولة عن القطاع الخاص
بينما هيئة الحكومة الرّقمية هي مسؤولة عن الجهات الحكومية
فنحن نمثل هنا أكثر الطلب
والسّعات الشركات موجودة
السّعات تقصد فيها البنية التحتية؟
البنية التحتية
مزودين الخدمات
الشركات اللي في القطاع
هم يجهزون الشركات، ونحن نعمل مع الجهات الحكومية
ويكون دائمًا في بيننا تواصل وموائمة كاملة
أيضًا دور مهم للزملاء في سدايا
الهيئة السعودية للبيانات والذكاء الاصطناعي
وعندهم أدوار مختلفة
هم مشغّل ما في شك للخدمات الرّقمية على مستوى الحكومة
ولكن أيضًا عندهم دور تنظيمي وطني
على مستوى البيانات
وهو منظم وطني للبيانات
وهم أيضًا يشغّلون خدمات حكومية رقميّة
مثل قناة التكامل الحكومي
مثل الشبكة الحكومية الموحدة
مثل أبشر وتوكلنا وإحسان
وغيرها من منصات وطنية نحن فخورين فيها جدًّا
أيضًا الهيئة الوطنية الأمن السيبراني دورهم وطني
على مستوى الأمن السيبراني
وهم دورهم جاي كذا عمودي
بشكل كامل على كل القطاعات
حتى نضمن إن شاء الله أن عندنا الحماية والأمن المطلوب
من تطور البناء إلى أناقة التصميم
ورفاهية الخدمات مع تميّز الموقع
حلول سكنيةٌ مبتكرة
ومستدامةٌ مع شركة صفا للاستثمار
المزيد في وصف الحلقة
الملحوظ أن كل هذه الهيئات قاعدة تقوم بدور منظّم
مثلما أنت تفضّلت
إلا هيئة سدايا
هيئة سدايا داخلة في التّشغيل
لدرجة أنها تشغل منصّة مسؤولة عن التبرعات
هذا يتعارض مع اللي بدأنا فيه حديثنا
بأنه انتقلنا نحن في يسّر من مشغل إلى
هيئة الحكومة الرّقمية المنظم دور الحكومة تنظم
ليش سدايا الاستثناء الوحيد اللي قاعد يدخل في التشغيل
ويسوي توكّلنا، ويسوي إحسان
ويسوي منصات مختلفة، ما تحس في تعارض هنا؟
لا بالعكس، أنا أشوف أن داخل سدايا في حوكمة
منضبطة بشكل كامل، أنت لو تدخل داخل سدايا
في مكتب البيانات الوطنية
وأيضًا داخل سدايا في جهاز خاص بالتشغيل
اللي هو مركز المعلومات الوطني
اللي هو بدأ من سنوات طويلة
فالمسؤول عن التنظيم هو مكتب البيانات الوطنية
بقيادة أخوي معالي الدكتور طارق الشدّي
والمسؤول عن التشغيل اللي هو مركز المعلومات الوطني
بقيادة معالي الدكتور عصام الوقيت
والكل الحقيقة بإشراف معالي أبو عبدالعزيز
الدكتور عبدالله الشرف
اليوم هذه الجهات تعمل مع بعض
وفي بينها تنسيق عالي
أنا لن أدّعي اليوم أن على المستوى الشامل
لا على مستوى الشركات ولا على مستوى الجهات الحكومية
ولا على مستوى الوظائف
سواءً كانت تطبيقات أو منصّات
أو أمن سيبراني أو بيانات، لا يزال هناك بلا شك فرص دائمًا
أن نراجع وفرص للتطوير والتحسين
والمهم عندنا ما في شك المستفيدين
وأيضًا المستثمرين في القطاع
حتى نضمن أن نقدم لهم أفضل خدمات
وأفضل تنظيمات وأفضل بيئة استثمارية
جميل، أنا لو بلخصها أبو صبا
في بنية تحتية وسعة أو شبكة
وهذه هيئة الاتصالات هي المسؤولة عن
تنظيم اللاعبين فيها سواءً شركات اتصالات
أو شركات تقنية معلومات
صحيح
مرجعهم هيئة الاتصالات
أنتم هيئة الحكومة الرّقمية
المسؤولين عن كل الخدمات الحكومية الرّقمية
بالضّبط
أنتم المنظم لهذه الخدمات والمشرف عليها
وهذه الخدمات سينتج عنها بيانات
المسؤول عن هذه البيانات هي هيئة سدايا
هيئة البيانات والذكاء الاصطناعي مسؤولة عن
إدارة و حوكمة كل هذه البيانات
اللي تنتج عنها الخدمات الحكومية الرّقمية
وفي كل هذا العالم الرّقمي
فيه خطر سيبراني ينتج عن
أن نحن اليوم صرنا موجودين في الفضاء الرّقمي
فهنا دور هيئة الأمن السيبراني
أن تضع السياسات اللي تحمي
كل هذه المكتسبات الرّقمية
من الهجمات السيبرانية، كذا نرتبها؟
بالضّبط 100% ويمكن إضافة على اللي ذكرت
الجهة المشغّلة
سواءً كانت شركة أو حتى جهة حكومية
إذا كان فيها خدمات حكومية رقميّة
هي دائمًا المسؤولة
هي المسؤولة عن تطوير وتشغيل خدماتها
هي المسؤولة عن بياناتها وهي المسؤولة أيضًا
عن الجوانب المتعلقة بالأمن السيبراني
ولكن المنظمين سواءً سدايا أو الأمن السيبراني
أو الحكومة الرّقمية هم يضعون التنظيمات
ويتابعون الامتثال
ولكن المستوى الأخير اللي هو مستوى التشغيل بلا شك
هو المسؤول بالنهاية
ويضمن أنه يطبق المعايير بالشكل المطلوب
جميل، يفترض أنه الآن فهمنا المشهد
فهمنا أدوار الجهات المختلفة
تعال نتكلم أبو صبا خلال سنتين
من تأسيس الهيئة للآن
كمّلنا تقريبًا سنتين وأربعة شهور على الهيئة
سنتين وشهر على قيادتك للهيئة
فأيش اللي تحقّق في الفترة الماضية؟
الحقيقة تحقّق الكثير
ولا أظن الحقيقة أنه هيئة الحكومة الرّقمية
وزملائي في الحكومة الرّقمية هو من حقّق هذا الإنجاز
ولكن الإنجاز بدون أدنى شك
لدى القطاعات والجهات الحكومية
اليوم دورنا نحن ممكّن وداعم
ونساعد على الجوانب اللي لها علاقة بالتنظيم والإشراف
ولكن الأبطال هم الجهات الحكومية
اسمح لي أولًا أن أبدأ مع الجهات الحكومية
وإنجازات الجهات الحكومية بعدين نقول:
أيش الحكومة الرّقمية ساندت فيه
وخلني في البداية يمكن أتكلم عن القطاع الصّحي
الأبطال في وزارة الصحة
بقيادة معالي أبو فيصل الجلاجل
الحقيقة عندهم مستشفى افتراضي
هو الأكبر من نوعه في العالم
هذا المستشفى يربط أكثر من 160 مستشفى في السعودية
ويقدّم خدمات تتجاوز 200 خدمة
الهدف هنا ليس العمل الافتراضي
ولكن بالنتيجة والأثر
اليوم قاعدين نشوف
عمليات جراحية لقلب مفتوح
يتم إجراءها عن بعد باستخدام المستشفى الافتراضي
وأيضًا استطاعوا باستخدام هذه الخدمات الافتراضية
أنهم يخفضّون الاستخدام على الأسرّة
ويزيدون السعات تقريبًا 40% لما يتعلق بمرض القلب
و أيضًا اليوم 25% من المواعيد كلها تقدم افتراضيًا
وهذا الأثر اللي وصلنا له ولله الحمد
ولو أخذ أيضًا أحد النماذج في منظومة الصحة
الهلال الأحمر على سبيل المثال
اليوم سيارة الإسعاف اللي نشوفها في الشوارع
قاموا بالنجاح جدًّا مبهر
واستطاعوا أنهم يربطون هذه السيارة بالمستشفيات
فأيش اللي حصل؟
أظن أنهم وصلوا تقريبًا ثلاثين مستشفى الآن
وعرضت بالمناسبة في مؤتمر ليب الأخير
الفكرة بشكل مختصر أن المستشفى
يصير عارف بالحالة قبل ما يصل المريض
أو تصل الحالة إلى المستشفى
ليش؟ لأنه ما في شك في قراءات حيوية كثيرة
في مطلوب بيانات للطبيب والجهاز الطبي في المستشفى
أنه يكون جاهز حتى أنه يتدخل
تحديدًا فيما يتعلق بالجلطات القلبية
طيب لما ربطنا السيارات بالمستشفيات
أيش اللي صار؟
استطاعوا
يقلّلون الفترة اللي يحتاجها الطبيب أو المستشفى
فترة الاستجابة
من ستة ساعات إلى ساعة واحدة
فهذا نجاح مبهر الحقيقة
للزملاء في منظومة الصحة
ونحن بالمناسبة عرضناها في قاتنر سنبوزي
والعام الماضي الزملاء في الصحة هم من عرض
والحقيقة كانت مبهرة جدًّا للدول الأكثر تقدمًا
على مستوى الخدمات الرّقمية في العالم
وكيف أنه استطعنا من خلال الأبطال في وزارة الصحة
أن نقدم نموذج رائع جدًّا
أنا أتذكر على، آسف لو قاطعتك على هذا المثال
زرت المهندسة منى السبيعي
صحيح، وهي من قدم بالمناسبة في برشلونة
هي مديرة المستشفى الافتراضية
أخذت فيني جولة على المستشفى
شفت حالات محدّدة لأشخاص يتعالجون
في صعوبات النطق
في الصوت
في حالات تبدو أنها بسيطة
لكن أثرها على الإنسان جوهري اجتماعيًا
وفي مخالطته للناس، وحديثه مع الناس
وشفت بشكل مباشر
حالات والتطور اللي صار في هذه الحالات
وروني مثال كان مبهر في موضوع
أنه أحيانًا الرعاية التلطيفية أو الرعاية السريرية لشخص
ما عاد تحتاج تسوي له إلا إنك بس تراقب حالته
فوجود الأساور أو القراءات الحيوية
ومتابعتها بشكل لحظي من المركز هنا
لمدن ومحافظات في أنحاء السعودية
كان عندهم سرعة استجابة أعلى من لما كانت المراقبة
من المستشفى نفسه اللي موجود في المدينة
لأنها قراءة رقميّة أو إلكترونية
فلحظيًا أول ما
تراجعت قراءاته الحيوية هذا المريض مباشرةً
السوار أو المستشعر أو الحساس الموجود عنده
أعطى إشارة
فأنقذت حالات ما هي بسيطة
فصراحةً تجربتهم جدًّا ممتازة ومشرفة
بس عشان أفهم دور الحكومة الرّقمية
أيش كان دورها في مثل هذه القصة؟
عشان نأخذها كمثال
لعلاقتكم أنتم بالخدمات الحكومية الرّقمية
اللي قاعدة تقدمها الجهة
بلا شك، الدور هو توفير التنظيمات المطلوبة
العمل مع الزملاء في وزارة الصحة
لتقديم كل الدعم اللي هم يحتاجونه
الجوانب المتعلقة أيضًا في المشتريات والميزانية
العمل أيضًا على تدريب الكوادر
وجوانب أخرى كثيرة متعدّدة
بلا شك، اليوم الذي حصل في وزارة الصحة هو نموذج عالمي
وهو بالمناسبة عمر يمكن يحتاج حلقة لوحده
التّحول الذي صار في وزارة الصحة
وعندنا نماذج أخرى كثيرة
خلني بتكلم على وزارة العدل
آسف قبل ما نروح وزارة العدل
عشان نغطي كل الجوانب
لما نتكلم على الصحة في هذا الجانب المشرق
وفي الجانب المزعج جدًّا
هو موضوع تعدد المنصّات
بالذات وزارة الصحة جهاز مرتبط
بناس عادةً أكبر سنًا، أقل احتكاكًا بالخدمات الرّقمية
تم إيذائهم فعلًا صار في إيذاء من موضوع المنصّات
أنا والدتي فترة الكورونا وقت التطعيمات واللقاحات
تبهدلت ما بين منصّة صحتي ومنصّة ما أدري أيش هو
في بعثرة في المنصّات ولا في ربط ما بينهم
هنا لازم اسم المستخدم وكلمة سر
أو كلمة دخول ومعرّف
فعلاً صار الموضوع أسوأ وأكثر مشقةً
من لما كانت بالطريقة التقليدية
وهذا يتعارض مع اللي حكينا عنه في البداية
إنه يفترض أن تعطي تجربة مستخدم أعلى
اللي صاير في الصحة مؤذي جدًّا
أنا أعتقد أنه بحول الله تعالى الزملاء تجاوزوا ذلك
ونحن عملنا معهم بشكل مفصّل
على وضع خارطة طريق واضحة جدًّا
وقبل أيام الزملاء عرضوها في لجنة التّحول الرّقمي
كل القطاع الصحي
آسف أبو صبا ودّي نأخذها كقضية
اشرح لنا بداية رصد المشكلة
أول ما رصدوا طبعًا
النقاش بينكم، وكيف الوصول لحل؟
وشلون يطبق الحل؟
ودّي نأخذها كقضية كاملة
هو طبعًا بالبداية لما شفنا أن كثير...
خلنا نبدأ من المريض
يمكن المريض هو أهم مستفيد الآن للخدمات الصحية
بلا شك كان في تطبيقات كثيرة جدًّا
ولما عُرضت الحالة
على زملاء المسؤولين في وزارة الصحة، وجدناهم
أنتم رصدتوها؟
نحن رصدناها ولقيناهم شغّالين عليها
قالوا: نعم هذه صحيحة وبالفعل نحن نحتاج
أن نعمل عليها وخلونا نعمل معكم كفريق واحد
حتى نضمن أن الخدمات بتكون بالشكل المطلوب
الهدف بالنسبة لنا أن يكون في اتفاق
على التوجه وتوقف النزيف
وشلون توقف النزيف؟
إنك ما تضيف منصات جديدة
وقّفنا النزيف من فترة
أعتقد من سنة الآن أو أكثر، وبدأنا نشاهد
انخفاض في عدد المنصّات
صاروا واضح عندهم أنه كل فترة
والله المنصّة هذه تقفل
وخلاص تنتقل للمنصّة الموحدة لخدمات المريض
واليوم طبعًا تعدد المنصّات يساعد في سرعة الإنجاز
وقد يكون مناسب ترى في مرحلة معينة
ولكن لا يجب أبدًا إنك تستمر عليه
يجب أن يكون عندك خطة واضحة ومترابطة
حتى تضمن أن كل الخدمات بتكون عندك في منصّة واحدة
فاليوم الخطة واضحة
ثلاثة منصات في القطاع الصحي
منصّة واحدة للمريض اللي هي منصّة صحتي
يمكن تطبيق صحتي كلنا نستخدمه اليوم
وفيه عليه عملية تطوير شاملة
ولعل الزملاء يكون لهم فرصة معك
أخوي عمر يعرضون كل التفاصيل
وفي تطبيق آخر للممارس الصحي
هذا الممارس الصحي مهم جدًّا دوره
كل الممارسين الصحيين أيضًا لهم تطبيق خاص
والخدمات اللي يحتاجها الممارس الصّحي
تختلف عن الخدمات اللي يحتاجها بلا شك المريض
بالإضافة لمنصّة أخرى تتعلق بالأعمال الداخلية
الخاصة بوزارة الصحة
فاليوم نحن هذا العمل
هذا النتيجة اللي وصلتوا لها؟
هذه النتيجة والحمدلله
أنه ثلاثة منصات؟
بالضّبط نعم
مقارنةً بكم منصّة سابقًا؟
أعتقد أنه كانت تتجاوز عشرين منصّة
فقط للمريض تتجاوز عشرين
واليوم شفنا النتائج هذه
والعمل الحقيقة في نموذج تحولي شامل في وزارة الصحة
متى تصير بس تطبيق واحد؟
أعتقد قريبًا جدًّا
هل لما تشتغلون معهم تحطون خط زمني أو خطة زمنية؟
بلا شك، نحن عندنا طال عمرك اتفاقية نوقعها
وقّعنا مع كل الزملاء
اللي صار عندنا اتفاق واضح لما يتعلق دمج المنصّات
وخلني أعطيك يمكن بالمجمل
كل الجهات الحكومية نهاية العام الماضي
أو مو نهاية العام الماضي يمكن تقريبًا في أكتوبر
في وقت ملتقى الحكومة الرّقمية
كان عدد المنصّات تقريبا 816 أو حولها عدد المنصّات
اليوم عندنا 630 منصّة
لأول مرة يمكن آخر عشرين سنة
بدأ يقل عدد المنصّات
على مستوى الجهات الحكومية
لأنه صار في عملية ضبط
اليوم ما تقدر تطلق منصّة
إلا لما ترفع طلب
ومبررات واضحة وقضية أعمال
إلى الحكومة الرّقمية، والحكومة الرّقمية تراجع
الحقيقة اليوم أغلب الطلبات نرفضها
ونرجع للجهة الحكومية
ونقول له: طيب أنت عندك المنصّة الفلانية
ولا الموقع الإلكتروني الفلاني ليش ما تقدم من خلاله؟
والأغلب أيضًا ييجي بالتأييد، الجهة الحكومية تؤيدنا
وأيضًا لو تشوف عدد الخدمات
وخلني ممكن أستطرد فيها بشكل سريع
اليوم كم عدد الخدمات الحكومية؟
نتكلم تقريبًا عن 4600 خدمة
اليوم بعد المراجعة والتأكد منها
من الجهات الحكومية وتشوف عدد المنصّات
المنصّات تقريبًا 630
يعطيك المعدل أقل من عشرة خدمات للمنصّة الواحدة
وهذا يبين لك الإشكالية
أنت تفتح منصّة وطلب واحد
وتحط فيه والله عدد قليل جدًّا من الخدمات
هذا يربك
وأيضًا من الصعب إنك تحط يمكن
200-300 خدمة في منصّة واحدة
هذا هو برنامج الحكومة الشاملة اللي اليوم نعمل عليه
مع الشركاء في الجهات الحكومية
ويمكن بستطرد عليه بس ودّي أكمل
إن سمحت لي القطاعات
نحن قلنا: الصحة بس ما نبغى ننسى البقية
لإنهم أيضًا متميزين، وزارة العدل
وزارة العدل اليوم 95% من الجلسات القضائية تقدّم عن بعد
و 100% من الخدمات تقدم بشكل إلكتروني
طيب هل هذا إنجاز؟ بلا شك
وزارة العدل ما يشوفون أن هذا إنجاز
الإنجاز الحقيقي أيش هو؟
أنه اليوم استغنوا عن زيارة
ثمانية عشر مليون مراجع إلى المحاكم سنويًا
أنت متخيلها عمر!
ثمانية عشر مليون مراجع اليوم ما يحتاجوا ييجون المحاكم
وليس هذا فقط
لما نتكلم عن القيمة والأثر والكفاءة والإنتاجية
لو نأخذ على سبيل المثال في محاكم الأحوال الشخصية
سابقًا من فتح القضية أو رفع القضية
إلى صدور الحكم
كانت تقريبًا بالمعدل تأخذ نحو 219 يوم
اليوم ما تأخذ إلا ثلاثين يوم
هذا باستخدام الخدمات الرّقمية والتقنية
بالإضافة للتمييز الكبير اللي عند الزملاء
بقيادة معالي الشيخ الصمعاني وفريق عمله الرائع
بمراجعة الإجراءات واستخدام التقنية بشكل مثالي
المحكمة الافتراضية اليوم في السعودية
نموذج رائد بدون أدنى شك
اليوم لما نشوف المعايير والمتطلبات الدولية
في المؤشرات الدولية
نفخر جدًّا بقصة النجاح في الصحة
وأيضًا قصة النجاح في العدل
وقصص النجاح الأخرى
اللي خلني أمر عليها أيضًا بشكل سريع
أنا ما ودّي أنسى وزارة الداخلية
وزارة الداخلية هم الرّواد
وهم من بدأ الحقيقة رحلة التّحول هذه
وذكرنا قبل شوي
تقريبًا نحو ثمانية عشر مليون في وزارة العدل
اللي ما يحتاج إنهم يراجعون المحاكم
طيب كم في وزارة الداخلية؟
160 مليون زيارة إلى إدارات وأقسام وزارة الداخلية
سواءً من جوازات أو مرور أو غيره
اليوم ما نحتاجها
هذا هو الرقم الذي وفّر ما يصل إلى
سبعة عشر مليار ريال سنويًا فقط لوزارة الداخلية
بسبب هذه الخدمات المقدمة
الوفر هذا
مو بس على الحكومة، ولكن أيضًا على المواطن
وهذا له أثر واسع
الأرقام اللي نذكرها اليوم في العدل، وفي الداخلية
وفي الصحة، وفي القطاعات الأخرى
هذا يقلّل الانبعاثات الكربونية
هذا يخفف من الازدحام
هذا يساعدنا على تقليل التكلفة ورفع الكفاءة
والإنتاجية بشكل كبير، وهذا اللي نشوفه اليوم
بأثر واضح الحقيقة في قطاعات مختلفة
وبما أننا ذكرنا مجموعة أمثلة
ودّي أفهم
أيش هي الممارسات اللي ما ترضيكم؟
نحن ما حنذكر أمثلة عشان ما نورطكم مع أي أحد
بس أيش هي الممارسات اللي إذا لاحظتوها
مباشرةً تتدخلون، وتتواصلون مع الجهة
وتحاولون تعملون على تجاوز مثل هذه الممارسة؟
نحن ضربنا مثال في الصحة لكثرة المنصّات
اللي تتعب المراجع أو المستفيد
أيش في الممارسات إذا لاحظتوها تبدأوا تتدخلون؟
ممتاز، طبعًا نحن اليوم عندنا برنامج الحكومة الشاملة
يتعلق بحوكمة المنصّات
عندنا برنامج آخر مهم جدًّا
اللي هو رحلات الحياة
اللي لا نقبل فيه أبدًا
أن تعمل الجهات الحكومية بشكل منفرد
اليوم لا يهم من هي الجهة الحكومية
اللي تقدم الخدمة، ولا يهم أيضًا
ما هي المنصّة التي تقدم الخدمة؟
أنا قدّامي حكومة المملكة العربية السعودية
حكومة المملكة العربية السعودية
المفروض الشعارات هذه ما تدخلوني فيها
بالضّبط، سيفين ونخلة نحن نقدم خدمة وحدة
ما يهم، نحن ما بين بعض الجهات الحكومية
وما بين قنوات التواصل ما بيننا
المفروض أننا ننجز العمل
ونعطي التجربة والكفاءة والإنتاجية
فهذا اللي اليوم ما نقبله
ونسعى طبعًا مع شركائنا في الجهات الحكومية كلها
لضمان تقديم الخدمة بالشكل المطلوب
أيش هي رحلات الحياة؟
والحمدلله صار فيها نجاح سواءً في الإسكان
ولا أيضًا في المواليد
خلني أخذ على سبيل المثال المواليد
هذا عامل مميز
ما بين وزارة الصحة
والمستشفى اللي يتبع وزارة الصحة
وما بين وزارة الداخلية ووكالة الأحوال المدنية
اليوم المولود تدخل على منصّة وحدة
اللي هي منصّة أبشر
وتوصل لك شهادة الميلاد وكرت العائلة بشكل واحد
ما يحتاج تروح لوزارة الصحة
ولا تروح للمستشفى، هذا ربط كامل من خلال
الخدمات والأصول التقنية الموجودة عندنا
التي تساعدنا نقدم الخدمة بالشكل المطلوب
فاليوم اللي نسعى له
وأيضًا لا يزال أمامنا عمل كبير في المستقبل
أن نضمن أن اليوم في عمل مشترك وتنسيق
وموائمة كاملة ما بين كل الجهات، من خلال
برنامج الإصلاحات ورحلات الحياة
حتى نضمن أن الخدمات مقدمة بالشكل المثالي للمستفيد
ونحن أيضًا نسمع للمستفيد
غير برنامج الحياة نحن عندنا قنوات متعدّدة
نضمن أننا نسمع بالشكل المثالي للمستفيد
فإذا لاحظنا وجود مشكلة
يتم رصدها بشكل مباشر
التواصل مع الجهة الحكومية
تقديم الدعم اللازم للجهة الحكومية
حتى نضمن أنه ما في تأخير
وبذلك معالجتها بالشكل المطلوب
وأرغب وأؤكد أنه صراحة لا نجد إلا استجابة مباشرة
ودعم كامل وتواصل
ولله الحمد الأغلب يتم حلّه بوقت قصير جدًّا
اسمح لي أبو صبا أفضفض شوية في هالجزئية
أنا في هالمبنى هذا تحديدًا
سمعت في 2021
عن موضوع الرحلات الشاملة
أو رحلة المواطن و حتى خذوني في جولة
وشفت اللوحة الضخمة و فيها كم عدد الرحلات
وكانوا يقولون: في نهاية 2021 نخلص ثلاثة رحلات
في نهاية 2022 نخلص تسعة رحلات
اليوم نحن ثلاثة وعشرين ولا في ولا رحلة
أصبحت موجودة بالشكل اللي وصف لي
أنا وصف لي أنه منصّة وحدة حدخل
رحلتي كباحث عن عمل من أول ما أتخرج
إلى أن أحصل على الدعم
إلى أن أحصل على التدريب
إلى أن أقدّم على الوظائف
إلى أن أُربط بالتأمينات الاجتماعية
هذه كلها في منصّة وحدة
ونفس الشيء البحث عن سكن
الإيجار والتملك والقرض والإفرار
الربط مع ملاك اتحاد الملاك
كلها هذه منتظمة في منصّة وحدة
ولا شيء صار من هذه
نسمع عن الرحلات بس ما بعد شفناها
طيب ممتاز، هل ما صار شيء في الرحلات؟
ما أعتقد أنه هذا دقيق
أيش صار؟
بالفعل، صار مثلًا في رحلة المسكن
رحلة المسكن اليوم موجودة عند الزملاء في وزارة الإسكان
وتستطيع اليوم من منصّة سكني تمشي بالرحلات كاملة
في رحلة مهمة جدًّا قيادة الزملاء في وزارة التعليم
أيًضا تسجيل طلاب الصف الأول الابتدائي
ولكن أبي أرجع على المنصّة الوحدة
ذكرت أنت المنصّة الوحدة
نعم
وهذا يأخذني لحديثي في البداية
هل المنصّة الموحدة
غاية؟
هي غاية؟ أنا أقول:
الغاية هي رضا المستفيد وتقديم التجربة المطلوبة
والكفاءة والإنتاجية إلى آخره
اليوم خلنا نشوف دول العالم
أفضل دول العالم في الحكومة الرّقمية
حسب المؤشرات الدولية على الأقل
شوف مثلًا تطور الحكومة الإلكترونية
الأول دولة الدنمارك، هل عندها منصّة واحدة؟
الجواب لا، لا يوجد عندها منصّة واحدة
عندها أكثر من منصّة
بس ما عندها 600 منصّة؟
ما عندها 600 منصّة، بس ما عندها منصّة واحدة
عندنا 600 منصّة، كنا قبل سنة 800
صرنا 600 ونبي ننزل الآن
ولكن إذا أنت فكرت إنك تحطها بمنصّة واحدة
يتحوّل الغاية أو الوسيلة تتحوّل إلى غاية أو إلى هدف
أنا أظن
أنه اليوم يجب أن نطبق مفهوم الحكومة الشاملة
خلني بس بتكلم شوي عن الحكومة الشاملة
تكلمنا عن دمج المنصّات لازم تقلل
مو معقول عندك 600 منصّة هذا غير...
المفروض إنك تنزل بشكل كبير جدًّا
طيب أيش بعد؟
لازم يكون عندك خدمات مشتركة
أيش هي خدمات المشتركة أو المكوّنات المشتركة؟
لازم يكون عندك نفاذ موحد
لازم تكون عندك قنوات دفع واحدة
لازم يكون عندك قناة تكامل واحدة
شبكة موحدة، بمعنى إنك إذا جيت تسوي منصّة
تعتمد على نفس المكوّنات
بحيث أنه ما يتغير عليك كثير من الأشياء
ولا تحتاج إنك تسويها من البداية
وأيضًا جانب ثالث مهم جدًّا
نحن بدأناه اليوم
ونتوقع إن شاء الله خلال سنة أو سنتين راح نشوف نتائجه
اللي هو توحيد التصميم
لما تأخذ فكرة مثلًا الكود العمراني
على مستوى المدن، كيف إنك توحد الكود العمراني؟
هذا اللي اليوم حريصيين اليوم على عمله
في الحكومة الشاملة
بحيث أنك توحد نظام الألوان
توحّد هيكل التصميم، وين تحصل القائمة المنسدلة
وين تحصل والله الخيارات الموجودة
بحيث إذا دخلت على أبشر أو ناجز أو إعتماد أو قوة
أو أي منصّة أنت تقريبًا تشوف نفس الشيء
ولكن يمكن الشعار يختلف والمحتوى يختلف
وبنفس الوقت نعطي الفرصة للجهات الحكومية
أنها تتحرك وتنجز بشكل كبير
أكثر ما يميزنا في السعودية
بلا شك، موضوع المنصّات بها تعدد
أكثر ما يميزنا في السعودية هو توافرية الخدمة
ويمكن ندخل على بعض الأمثلة اللي نقارن مع دول العالم
وخلني مثلًا على سبيل المثال
أخذ إصدار وتجديد رخصة القيادة
اليوم هذه بالنسبة لنا شيء عادي
موجودة على منصّة أبشر، ونعتمد عليها بشكل كبير
اليوم هذه الخدمة غير متوفرة
في أفضل دول العالم التي هي دولة الدينمارك
في الحكومة الرّقمية، ولكنها موجودة عندنا اليوم وهذا واضح
اليوم على سبيل المثال لو أخذ الوكالات
و نحن الزملاء في وزارة العدل قبل أربعة سنوات
أوقفوا آخر وكالة
في المملكة المتحدة لا يوجد عندهم وكالات رقميّة
بل أنك قد تحتاج أن توكِّل محامي
حتى يروح المحكمة ويخلص لك الوكالات بالشكل المطلوب
أيضًا لو تأخذ على سبيل المثال
الخدمات البلدية، رخص الإنشاء
سواءً تريد أن تأخذ إذن أو إتمام بناء أو كذا
اليوم الموجودة على منصّة بلدي
وقيادة الأبطال في وزارة الشؤون البلدية
والقروية والإسكان، اليوم في كوريا الجنوبية
اللي هي أفضل دولة أيضًا في مؤشر البنك الدولي
لنضج الحكومة الرّقمية هي رقم واحد
اليوم الخدمات هذه ما هي موجودة، تطبع نموذج
لازم إنك تعبيه وتروح تراجع في القطاع
هذا اليوم هذا الموجود في السعودية
فاليوم نحتاج نتوازن نحتاج أن نوحد الشفرة
نحتاج أن نوحد المكوّنات
نحتاج أن نقلل المنصّات، ولكن نضمن
أنه بالنهاية الهدف ما يكون عندك منصّة واحدة
ولكن تضمن أن الخدمة بالشكل المطلوب
وعندك العدد المطلوب من المنصّات
بس مفهوم الرحلات ما زلتم مؤمنين فيه؟
بلا شك
الآن تدمجون منصات في وزارة واحدة
هل ممكن نشوف دمج عدّة منصات في وزارات مختلفة
في منصّة واحدة أو رحلة واحدة؟
نحن ما أتوقع طبعًا التطبيق الذكي
اللي هو كل الخدمات حكومية في مكان واحد
4000 خدمة في مكان واحد، ما هو منطقي
بس على الأقل رحلتي المرتبطة بمثلًا قطاع الأعمال
هل أقدر كرجل أعمال ألقى كل خدماتي في منصّة وحدة؟
اليوم وزارة الموارد البشرية عندها أكثر من منصّة
فأنت تدخل عشان شيء، ثم تطلع وتدخل على منصّة ثانية
عشان شيء ثاني، ثم تبتل
فقطاع الأعمال برضو قاعد اليوم يعاني من تعدد المنصّات
وكل واحد أربعة وعشرين ساعة السكرتير يكلمه
جاءك شفرة، أعطني الشفرة
تجربة ما هي بجيدة
فهل نحن نتكلم على مفهوم الرحلات
أنه هذه كلها تدمج في منصّة وحدة؟
ولا الهدف تقليص المنصّات كل وزارة عندها منصّة واحدة؟
ودّي أفهم مشروعكم، أيش مشروعكم؟
بالنسبة طبعًا للقطاع الأعمال بلا شك اليوم في عمل كبير
وفي منصّة موحدة للأعمال يعمل عليها
الزملاء في وزارة التجارة والمركز السعودي للأعمال
طبعًا بقيادة معالي الدكتور ماجد
وأيضًا من خلفهم الجهات الحكومية
اللي هم مثلما ذكرت العمل والتأمينات الاجتماعية
أيضًا الزكاة والضريبة والجمارك وكل الجهات
الهدف بكل تأكيد أنه يكون مكان واحد تدخل عليه
وتحصل الخدمات
والمكان هذا ما يكون فقط إعادة توجيه
هو عبارة عن واجهة
ولكن تكون إجراءات مترابطة تعطيك الخدمة بالشكل المطلوب
ذكرنا قبل قليل المواليد
وهذا المستهدف بكل تأكيد على
لما يخص قطاع الأعمال
وبدأنا خطوات على هذا الموضوع
والزملاء الحقيقة اليوم لو تدخل موجودة
(business.sa) موجودة
وبقيادة الزملاء الحقيقة العمل فيها كبير جدًّا
وأعتقد قطعنا شوط جدًّا ممتاز ونبي نشوف الآن
ذكرت وزارة الشؤون البلدية أو عفوًا
وزارة الموارد البشرية والشؤون الاجتماعية
الوزارة طبعًا فيها قطاعات مختلفة
فيها قطاع للعمل وفيها قطاع للشؤون الاجتماعية
وفيها قطاع أيضًا يتعلق
بيسمى الموظفين الحكوميين أو الخدمة المدنية
ثلاثة قطاعات رئيسية، ما يتعلق بقطاع العمل
هو فقط منصّة قوى
وهي المفروض تقدم كل الخدمات
ومنصّة قوى بالتنسيق بدون شك
مع الزملاء في المركز السعودي للأعمال
يكون بينهم الموائمة المطلوبة لتقديم الخدمة
بس مفهوم المنصّة الوحدة اللي فيها
كلما يخص عالم الأعمال
التأمينات الاجتماعية وغرفة تجارية
قوى والتراخيص، رخص المحلات حقتي
هل هذا توجه؟
إذا إيه متى نتوقع نشوف هذه المنصّة الموحدة؟
هذا طبعًا العمل القائم اليوم
هل في تاريخ اليوم محدد؟
أمانةً ما أقدر أعطي تاريخ
لكن الزملاء الحقيقة في وزارة التجارة
والمركز السعودي للأعمال يعملون عليه
بس هو المشروع هذا الهدف؟
بلا شك هذا المشروع، وهذا الهدف ونسعى لضمان
أن النتائج تكون عندنا بالشكل المطلوب
وبغى أؤكد أن المنصّة الموحدة ليست هدف
نحن نبغى الرحلة ونبغى التجربة بالشكل المطلوب
حتى نضمن أنه ما يكون عندنا تحديات، هذا الهدف
ونبغى نضمن أنه لا في تصميم الإجراءات
ولا طبعًا قبل الإجراءات السياسات، ولا توفير الخدمات الرّقمية
وترابط المنصّات فيما بينها
نحقق الهدف المطلوب
ذكرت يمكن بعض النماذج الآن في الإسكان
ولا كذلك في المواليد
لإنه نبغى نفس التجربة
تجربة تكون بهذا الشكل
ويكون عندنا هيكل موحّد
ومترابط بالشكل المطلوب
يمكن من الأشياء اللي دائمًا تذكر
لما نحكي عن قطاع الخدمات الحكومية الرّقمية
هو موضوع الشركات الحكومية التقنية
المشهد أنت تعرفه كل وزارة تسوي لها شركة تقنية
وهذه الشركة تأخذ خدمات هذه الوزارة
وتحولها وتصير هي اللي ماسكة بياناتها
وبعدين تبدأ تبيع هذه البيانات
أو تكون مسؤولة عن عمليات الربط
فلقينا فجأة عندنا ستة أو سبعة شركات
تقنية حكومية
احتكرت خدمات هذه الوزارات
فودّي أفهم أيش رأي الحكومة الرّقمية
في هذا الحراك اللي قاعد يصير
من الشركات التقنية الحكومية؟
ممتاز، خليني أفصّل في علاقتنا مع القطاع الخاص
إلى ثلاثة مسارات رئيسية
المسار الأول: هو ما يتعلق بالمشتريات
التي هي التكلفة زائد هامش الربح
اللي هو على نظام المنافسات والمشتريات الحكومية
اليوم في عمل كبير في هذا المسار
لو نحاول نحطه في رقم
تقريبًا نحو عشرين مليار ريال
هذا اليوم الذي تشتري الجهات الحكومية
من قطاع الاتصالات وتقنية المعلومات سنويًا
الذي هو التكلفة الزائدة
هذا طبعًا في عمل كبير في الفترة ماضية
يمكن أبرزه ما يتعلق
بالاتفاقيات الإطارية والسوق الإلكتروني
الآن عندنا أربعة اتفاقيات إطارية
سابقًا كنت تحتاج تنتظر 100 يوم من الطرح إلى الشراء
حتى تحصل على المنتج
اليوم خمسة أيّام فقط
وأحد الأمثلة مثلًا اللابتوب على سبيل المثال
إذا الجهة الحكومية تبغى تشتري
وتدخل على السوق
عندنا أشبه بأمازون داخل الحكومة
تشتري والمورد يجيبه عندك
وهذا طبعًا بالشراكة مع الزملاء في منظومة الماليّة
ووزارة الماليّة وهيئة كفاءة الإنفاق
وأيضًا الزملاء بالمركز
وأيضًا، تصنيف مقاولين
بالشراكة مع الزملاء في وزارة البلديات
عندنا تصنيف مقاولين واضح
وهدف تصنيف المقاولين
أنه نركز على الشركات التي تعطينا القيمة العالية
لا يكون عندنا شركات عبارة عن إعادة بيع أو بيع
وبذلك لا يكون عندي القيمة المطلوبة
الشركات التي تركز على البحث والتطوير
والابتكار وصناعة المنتجات
وعندها تركيز محدد في تقنية ناشئة
أو في مجال معين
وحقّقنا وفورات خلال هذه الفترة القصيرة
الآن تقريبًا نحو مليار ونصف ريال
الوفورات المحقّقة من مراجعة الكراسات
من تقديم التدريب
من وضع النماذج
مراجعة استخدام الدوائر الرّقمية وغيره من المجالات
ولا نزال نعمل حتى نضمن
أنه السوق هذا يكون بالشكل المثالي
وعلاقتنا مع القطاع الخاص تكون دائمًا بالشكل المتميز
ويكون في فرصة للشركات
أنها تدخل في هذا السوق بالشكل المطلوب
هذا النوع الأول
النوع الثّاني: هو ما يتعلق بالمشاركة بالدخل
نماذج المشاركة بالدخل
اللي هي أيضًا ترتبط بنظام المنافسات
والمشتريات الحكومية
وأيضًا بالقرار الوزاري الصادر من
معالي وزير الماليّة أبو فيصل
وهذا طبعًا مسار مهم جدًّا
اليوم بلا شك في مشكلة وفي تحدي
اليوم في احتكار
في ضعف في حوكمة الأسعار
ولا في تنافسية
وأيش سوينا طيب خلال الفترة الماضية؟
سوينا بيئة تنظيمية تجربية
تقريبًا كل الشركات، اللَّه يعطيهم العافية
دخلوا معنا وسجّلوا في البيئة التنظيمية التجربية
وسجلنا تقريبًا أغلب المنتجات، عندنا ما يزيد
عن خمسة وخمسين منصّة ومنتج
اليوم تقدّمها هذه الشركات للجهات الحكومية
وبحول اللَّه تعالى
نعمل السَّنة هذه 2023
رح نعلن عن الإطار التنظيبي
لترخيص أعمال الحكومة الرّقمية
اللي هو يعالج التحديات الموجودة اليوم
و أنا أؤكد فعلًا أنها موجودة
ونحتاج أن لا يكون عندنا احتكار
وتكون الأسعار منطقية جدًّا
وأيضًا لا يكون لدينا تحديات لما يتعلق بالجوانب التنافسية
ووجدنا الحقيقة من كل الشركات كل التعاون
وكل الشراكة
دورهم مهم جدًّا كان خلال يمكن العشرين سنة الماضية
وسيضل دورهم مهم جدًّا في المستقبل
وهم شريك أساسي
ونعمل معهم بإذن اللَّه لتقديم القيمة الكبيرة
النوع الثّالث:
غير التكلفة الزائدة وغير تقاسم الإيرادات
النوع الثّالث: هو ما يتعلق بإتاحة الأصول الرّقمية
وهذا مهم جدًّا لروّاد الأعمال
نحن حريصين اليوم كحكومة أن نوفر
الأصول الرّقمية لكل روّاد الأعمال والشركات
حتى أنهم يقدمون خدمات وتطبيقات ذات قيمة
ويمكن أبرز مثالين اللي هي البيانات المفتوحة
بحيث أنَّه نضمن البيانات متاحة لروّاد الأعمال
اليوم عندنا ما يزيد عن 6000 مجموعة بيانات متوفرة
وأيضًا ما يتعلق بالواجهات البرمجية
الواجهات البرمجية اللي هي الإيه بي آيز
سواءً كانت للاستعلام عن البيانات
أو حتى كانت عملياتية أو قاعدة انتقالية
بحيث أنه يربط مع الجهات الحكومية
هذا يساعد على الابتكار
ويساعد الحقيقة على تقديم بيئة تنافسية مثالية
في كل الثّلاثة مسارات نحن نعمل
ليس فقط عن تقاسم الإيرادات
في كل الثّلاثة مسارات نعمل
وبحول اللَّه تعالى
نقدم كل ما نستطيع حتى نضمن الشراكة المثالية
مع القطاع الخاص
الذي دوره مهم جدًّا خلال الفترة الجاية
فأنتم لستم راضين على الممارسات الاحتكارية
من الشركات المربوطة بوزارات محدّدة؟
بلا شك، اليوم نعتقد أنها فترة
وقد يكون لها أسبابها الفترة الماضية
اليوم نرغب المراجعة، ونرغب فتح السوق
ونرغب يكون في حوكمة للأسعار
وبالنهاية هي أصول حكومية
وسنضمن بإذن الله طبعًا
أنا عندي قناعة كاملة أنَّه سيكون
أو لا يزال هناك فرصة للنمو
والتوسع لهذه الشركات حتى مع وجود التنظيم
لما يتعلق بهذه الأصول
الفرصة اليوم موجودة
والقطاعات ما شاء اللَّه واعدة
عندنا قطاعات كبيرة اليوم واعدة داخل الحكومة
وفيها استثمار كبير
وأنا متأكد أن لهذه الشركات دور مهم جدًّا
هو الخطورة أبو صبا وأنت أخبر مني
يمكن هذا كذا استطراد على جنب
كنا نسولف في مجلس
فكانوا يقولون: أنَّ خطورة هذا النّموذج
أنه قاعد يصنع زي ما صار مثلًا في طفرة
2005 إلى 2015 الطفرة هذه
كانت كل المشاريع الحكومية
قاعدة تتركز على شركتين مقاولات، كبّرناهم
ضخّمناهم ما عطينا فرصة لباقي السوق
وصرنا أسرى لهم لما طاحوا
انكشف قطاع المقاولات
و اكتشفنا أنه ما عندنا أحد مؤهل قادر يبني
مرَّت الطَّفرة ولا صنعنا أبطال في قطاع المقاولات
ما نبغى طفرة الحكومة الرّقمية والتّحول الرّقمي تعدِّي
ونكتشف أنه ما عندنا إلا ثلاثة أو أربعة لاعبين
عايشين على وزارات محدّدة
وحتى هم هؤلاء ما قدروا يبيعون برة حدود الوطن
لأنَّهم خلاص شبعانين بالعقود اللي هنا
لم تُبنى عضلة التسويق
البيع للخارج
المنافسة
على مستوى إقليمي ومستوى دولي
لأنه خلاص هو شبعان بالعقود اللّي قاعدة تجي من هالجهة
وطفشنا القطاع الخاص
وطفشنا الشركات الصغيرة والمتوسطة
طلعناهم من السوق، لأنَّه هذا جالس
على بحر من البيانات محتكرها لحاله
وعقود مليارية سنوية
فالمشهد للجميع خسارة مضاعفة
المستفيد الوحيد هي الوزارة
لأنَّها لقت أحد توظّف فيه موظفينها برواتب عالية
وتجيب فيه مواهب
فالمشهد فعلًا
ما هو صحّي وآثاره الاقتصادية خطيرة
ومن زمان نسمع عن
كلام في حتى حلقتي مع معالي عبد العزيز الزوم
هيئة المنافسة
كان في حديث على هالجانب
بس اللي واضح أنه
الكعكة قاعدة تكبر لهذه الشركات ما هو العكس
حتى أنتم أول شركات رخصتوها
هي علم وثقة وتكامل
فما زلنا في نفس البحر ندور على هذه الأسماء
فهذا يمكن بدخل جيد على موضوع التراخيص
أيش كانت الفكرة من الترخيص لهالشركات؟
نعم الترخيص لهذه الشركات
طبعًا أنا لا أظن أن التحدي بهذا المستوى
مقارنة مع قطاعات أخرى
يمكن ذكرت المقاولات في فترة سابقة
لا، التحدي إن شاء اللَّه قادرين على السيطرة عليه
لا يزال في دور كبير لشركات من القطاع الخاص
بالإضافة للشركات الحكومية
ويتم الاعتماد عليها بشكل كبير
البيئة التنظيمية التجربية
ليش رخصنا للشركات هذه؟
نحن رخصنا عشان ننظم، نحن ما كنا نعرف البيانات
أول سؤال، أيش هي الخدمات هذه؟
كم مقابلاتها؟
أيش تصميمها؟
أيش تفاصيل العقود؟
هذه فكرة البيئة التنظيمية التجربية
أنت الآن تبغى تعرف الأساس
حتى تستطيع أنك تخطط للمستقبل وتبدأ بشكل
مدروس وواضح ومتدرج
تفصّل أيش الخطوات اللي تحتاج أنك تسويها
هذه الشركات دخلت
وسجلت معنا بشكل كامل
والتفاصيل اليوم موجودة
والآن في الاعتمادات النهائية إن شاء اللَّه قريبًا
بإذن الله وخلال هذا العام
نبدأ الإطار
و نبدأ عملية الانتقال، الانتقال صعبة
أنت عندك مسار جديد، ونبغى نتوسع فيه
التي هي المنصّات والمنتجات الجديدة
للشركات المرخصة كلها، ليس فقط هذه الشركات
وطبعًا عندنا مسار العقود القائمة
وكيف ننقل العقود القائمة من وضعها الحالي
إلى وضعها الجديد
نحن أيضًا حريصين
أنه نضمن أنه ما فيه تأثير على الخدمات
نحن بالنهاية المستفيد يهمّنا بشكل كبير
ونبغى نضمن أن العملية الجراحية هذه تتم بشكل مثالي
ودّي أسألك من يملك البيانات؟
هل كل وزارة تملك بياناتها؟
ولا من هو المالك للبيانات الموجودة في الجهات الحكومية؟
هو طبعًا أعتقد أن الوزارات هي المالكة للبيانات
بلا شك، اليوم الوزارة هي تملك الخدمات
وتملك البيانات، الوزارة أو أي جهة
تملك الخدمات، وتملك البيانات
وطبعًا في تنظيمات واضحة لها مرجع واضحة
تحدد ذلك ويمكن التنظيمات تفصّل
قد أكون أنا ما عندي التفاصيل بشكل كامل
لكن الزملاء في مكتب البيانات الوطنية
عندهم التطلبات التي تحدد
كافّة الممارسات والإجراءات المطلوبة
حتى أنك تتعامل مع هذه البيانات
ودّي أفهم هنا أيش عادةً دوركم في مثل الحالات؟
أنا على سبيل المثال زرت منصّة الحوادث المرورية
في مركز السّلام المرورية، أعتقد كذا اسمه
وكان عندهم لوحة حائ رائع جدًّا
على موضوع الحوادث المرورية وتوزيعها الجغرافي
وتوزيعها الزمني وتوزيعها مناطقيًا
كانت منصّة رائعة جدًّا
قلت لهم: ما شاء اللَّه هذه كل حوادثنا؟
قالوا: لا، هذه بس اللّي تباشرها وزارة النقل
قلت: طيب وين الباقي؟
ما قالوها بس اللّي أنا فهمته أنه
واضح الحوادث اللي عند البلدية
ما عطوهم وصولية على هذه المعلومات
الحوادث اللي يباشرها المرور
ما أعطوهم وصولية على المعلومات
الحوادث التي يباشرها الهلال الأحمر ما أعطوهم
فطلعت لدينا منصّة مشوهة
ما تعطي إلا جزء من المعلومة
بينما لو تداخلت كل هذه المعلومات
في مكان واحد
لأصبحت القيمة من هذه المنصّة أعظم بكثير
هل هذا ضمن ملعبكم؟
بما أنها منصّة حكومية، ولا هذه تبع هيئة البيانات؟
الزملاء طبعًا اليوم في سدايا
عندهم منصّة استشراف على سبيل المثال
كل البيانات اللي تجي من كافة القطاعات
حتى أنها تكون في منصّة واحدة تساعدنا باتخاذ القرار
واستخدمناها في كثير من الحالات
سواءً لا في التعليم أو في الإسكان أو في غيره
بحيث إنه نأخذ البيانات من أكثر من قطاع
وتكون موجودة عندنا في مكان واحد حتى نأخذ القرار المناسب
وبالمناسبة يمكن ذكرت قطاع النقل
قد لا يكون الحاجة عندهم أنه يحتاج كل البيانات موجودة
إنك إذا حطيت كل شيء اللي في البلديات
واللي في المرور
وبكون من الصعوبة التعامل مع اللوحة هذه
لاحتياج وزارة النقل أو هيئة النقل
هي على حسب الاحتياج
أنت أيش تحتاج اليوم ما في تحدي بتوفير البيانات
التّحدي اللي ذكرناه قبل شوي
هو يتعلق بالنماذج التجارية
عندنا تحدي في الاحتكار
صح
البيانات موجودة
والجهات الحكومية تتناقل البيانات
وعندنا بالمناسبة بنك بيانات وطني
موجود عند الزملاء في سدايا
والبيانات موجودة فيه متى ما احتجناها
نستطيع أنه نطلّع فيها أي استخدام
التحدي تجاري ويتعلق في الاحتكار والتنافسية
وهذا اللي إن شاء الله جاري العمل عليه
والتسعير تتدخلون فيه؟
كان كثير يتكلمون على تكلفة الربط مع أبشر
ولا تكلفة الربط مع منصّة أكس أو واي أو زيد
أنها في رسم عالي جدًّا
ولا يفرّق ما بين شركة عملاقة وما بين شركة ناشئة
بلا شك
هل تتدخلون في هذا الجانب؟
بلا شك، هذا من الأهداف وطبعًا تتكلم عن التحقق والنفاذ
وكافة هذه الخدمات
نحن حريصين اليوم أنه نراجع هالأسعار
ونتأكد أنها مناسبة للشرائح المحدّدة من المستفيدين
وكل الخدمات الأخرى
حتى نضمن أنها بالشكل المثالي
أتذكر في وثيقة رؤية لما أعلنت
لما أُطلقت في أبريل 2016
كان أحد الأهداف المنصوص عليها
في عام 2030 هو أن نكون
ضمن أفضل خمسة دول في الحكومة الإلكترونية
وين وصلنا في المؤشرات الدولية؟
عندنا يمكن أربعة مؤشرات دولية
أو يمكن خلني قبل الدولي عمر
خلنا نتكلم عن المحلي
أيش المؤشرات المحلية اللي اشتغلنا عليها
حتى يكون عندنا ربط واضح مع المؤشرات الدولية؟
عندنا محليًا أربعة مؤشرات
المؤشر الأول: هو قياس التّحول الرّقمي
وهذا بلا شك أنه يستهدف الجهات الحكومية
منظم الحكومة الرّقمية
والجهة التي يتم العمل معها اللي هي الجهة الحكومية
وهذا صار عليه تطور كبير ابتداءً من عام 2021
هي السنة اللي انطلقت فيها الهيئة
واليوم تحوّلنا إلى قاعدة الامتثال أو الامتثال
الآن صار عندنا وضوح بالمتطلبات
والاستجابة المطلوبة للجهات
هذا أول مؤشر، مؤشر التّحول الرّقمي في الجهات
أنتم وضعتوه تقيسون الجهات؟
بالضّبط
مين أحسن ثلاثة جهات في هذا المؤشر؟
أعتقد وزارة العدل كانت الأولى في العام الماضي
الثّاني أعتقد أنها وزارة الموارد البشرية
القوائم طبعًا كلها موجودة على موقع الهيئة
ممكن أي حد يحصل عليها وأعلنت في وقته
حلو، هذا المؤشر الأول؟
هذا الأول، الثّاني ما يتعلق بالمنتجات
اللي هو نضج التجربة الرّقمية هو السي أكس
أيش فرق النضج عن القياس؟
النضج يركّز على المنتج ويُشرك المستفيد
الأول قياس يشوف الجانب المؤسّسي
النضج لا، يشوف المستفيد ورأي المستفيد
ورضا المستفيد وتجربته
على سبيل المثال
العام الماضي اللي شارك معنا
تقريبًا نحو عشرين ألف مستفيد في تقييم المنصّات
كان عندنا أظن اثنا عشر منصّة
السنة هذه بإذن الله راح نوصل أربعة وعشرين منصّة
وبإذن الله راح نتجاوز 100 ألف مستفيد اللي رح يدخلون
أخذتوا رأيهم؟
أخذنا رأيهم وأعطونا تقييم وعملنا استبيانات كاملة
بالإضافة إلى ما يسمى بالمتسوق الخفي
أو تسوق غامض نحن نروح وندخل ونجرّب ونشوف
وطبعًا هذه لها أيضًا ضوابط ومعايير واضحة
هذا المؤشر الثّاني
نضج التجربة الرّقمية
مين أفضل اثنين فيه؟
أعتقد أبشر كان هو الأفضل العام الماضي
وإن شاء الله السنة هذه عاد نشوف من الأفضل
عندنا عدد أكبر السنة هذه
العام الماضي كان اثنا عشر
السنة هذه أربعة وعشرين، نستهدف أربعة وعشرين
وبإذن الله العام القادم يكون عندنا عدد أكبر أيضًا
المؤشر الثّالث؟
الثّالث يمكن اللي أعلننا عنه قبل كم يوم
وهو يتعلق بالمستقبل
خاص
بتقنيات المستقبل
تقينات المستقبل وجاهزية الجهات الحكومية
لتبني التقنيات الناشئة وهذا مهم جدًّا
لوضع مسار واضح لحكومة المستقبل
اليوم لما يجينا متطلب من قطاعات الأعمال
داخل الحكومة
حريصين جدًّا أنه ما نفكر بس نسوي منصّة
ولا نسوي موقع إلكتروني
نبغى نشوف التقنيات الجديدة
نبغى نشوف طائرات بدون طيار
نبغى نشوف الذكاء الاصطناعي
نبغى نشوف سلاسل الكتل وغيره
ولله الحمد
طبعًا في البداية هو أول مرة نطرحه
وسويناه بشكل تجريبي
أعتقد شارك معنا ثلاثة عشر جهة حكومية
وأعلنا الجهات عشرة جهات أُعلنت
أول جهة كانت هيئة الاتصالات
ثاني جهة كانت وزارة العدل
وجدنا نماذج رائدة جدًّا الحقيقة
ويمكن أهم التقنيات المستخدمة كانت واضحة
اللي هي الميتا فيرس والواقع المعزز
وهذه كانت بارزة بالمناسبة في البلديات والإسكان
أنهم يحتاجون الثري دي
ويحتاجون عرضها بشكل متميز
وأيضًا الذكاء الاصطناعي كان واضح جدًّا
سلاسل الكتل أيضًا موجودة بشكل جيد
طائرات بدون طيار أيضًا
شاهدنا نماذج للطائرات بدون طيار
بالذات عند البلديات وكشف الحفر
والآن نبغى ندفع بهذا الاتجاه بشكل كبير
للاعتماد على التقنيات بالشكل المطلوب
وهذا مهم يمكن حكومة السعودية
من أفضل الدول اللي تركّز على هذا الجانب
ليس فقط على الجانب التقليدي من الخدمات الرّقمية
ولكن أيضًا على تقنيات المستقبل
أيش الرابع؟
الرابع يتعلق بالمحتوى الرّقمي وكفاءة محركات البحث
وهذا طبعًا نحن نعمله بشكل تجريبي داخليًا
مع الجهات الحكومية، ما نشرناه إلى الآن
لكن إن شاء الله خلال سنة من اليوم راح ننشر
بإذن الله أفضل 100 موقع
وهو ما يستهدف فقط الجهات الحكومية
الجهات الحكومية وشبه الحكومية أيضًا
أيش فكرته هذا؟
هدفه طبعًا أنه يتأكد أن المحتوى الموجود في المنصّات
في المواقع الإلكترونية
موجود بالشكل المثالي
يشوف الجودة
يشوف التحرير
يشوف الصور
يشوف ظهورك في محركات البحث مثل قوقل وغيره
وهذا مهم جدًّا بالنسبة لنا
اليوم السعودية لاعب دولي مهم جدًّا
فنحن حريصين أنه ليس فقط توافرية الخدمة
وليس فقط رضا المستفيد
ولكن لما يكون عندنا محتوى جيّد
وجودة جيدة وتحرير وصياغة جيدة
وظهور على محركات البحث
هذا راح يساعد بظهورنا بالشكل المثالي
هذه الأربعة مؤشرات الداخلية
اللي أنتم تقيسون فيها
بالضّبط
وتساعدكم في تحسين موقعنا في المؤشرات الدولية
قبل ما نروح المؤشرات الدولية، مين متعبينك؟
الأربعة المقصود ولا شلون؟
لا، مين الجهة الحكومية اللي ما فلحت في الأربعة؟
بالعكس، ما في عندنا جهة حكومية
خلني أورطك شوي
أبدًا بالعكس، لا يوجد
وعلى فكرة لما جهة حكومية
تطلب دعم ولا جهة حكومية، تقول: ما أقدر
ولا جهة حكومية تقول: أبرك الساعات
نحن عندنا فرق خاصة لدعم الجهات الحكومية
والمتابعة معها بالشكل المطلوب
نحن بالعكس إذا هم ما جاؤونا ترى نحن نروح لهم
نقول: المستفيد عنده ملاحظات
في بعض الجوانب اللي تحتاج دعم
أنا لاحظتكم دبلوماسيين تعلنون الأفضل
بس ما تعلنون بقية الترتيب
فما ندري من هو الأسوأ، مقصودة هذه؟
نعم بلا شك مقصودة
ليش؟
نحن نعرف من هو، ترى اللي في أقل أو أسفل القائمة
وداخل الحكومة هذا معروف ويُرسل
وتعلمونه وتجلسون معه وتحاولوا تطورونه؟
ونعلمه يروح لتقرير، وفي تقارير متابعة كاملة
بس ما هو ضروري أن نعلن من هو الأقل
نحن نقول: من هو الأفضل عشان نحط المنافسة والتحفيز
المنافسة هذه مهمة جدًّا وشفناها بآخر سنتين
وهذا برضو ترى كان من الجوانب
اللي فكرنا فيه كثير في البدايات
ننشر ولا ما ننشر، وكان في حوار وجدل كبير
داخل الهيئة على هذا الموضوع
أنا كنت أنادي دائمًا في النشر بعض زملائي
كانوا عندهم نوع من التحرج
وطبعًا وصلنا لآخر صياغة أنه خلنا ننشر المتميزين على الأقل
وكما لاحظت في يمكن الأربعة مؤشرات
أو الثّلاثة مؤشرات اللي نشرت
نحن ننشر المتميزين
هل نبي ننشر الأقل من ذلك؟
ما عندنا خطة إلى الآن
لكن أعتقد الوضع الحالي قاعد يساعدنا بشكل كبير
ويظهر جوانب التميّز
على سبيل المثال التقنيات الناشئة لما نُشر
جاءت لي الكثير من إشادات من منظمات دولية
أنه كيف السعودية استطاعت أنها تطوّع
وتستفيد من التقنيات الناشئة؟
لأنه هو ليس فقط إنك تحط تصنيف وترتيب
تقول: والله أيش سوت وزارة الزراعة؟
أيش سوت وزارة البلديات؟
أيش سوت وزارة العدل؟
وكيف استخدمت التقنية؟
ولا هو بكلام إنشائي، بالأرقام
نحط أرقام واضحة ومحدّدة
كيف ساعدتنا إننا نخلق قيمة بالشكل المطلوب
الأربعة مؤشرات هذه كلها لها طبعًا
معايير محدّدة ومناظير محدّدة
نحاول نربطها بحد كبير جدًّا مع المؤشرات الدولية
حتى نُساعد زملائنا في الجهات الحكومية
على العمل بشكل مثالي
أبدأ يمكن إذا سمحت لي نأخذ المؤشرات الدولية
أي تفضل
نبدأ الأول اللي هو طبعًا الأقدم
اللي هو مؤشر تطور الحكومة الإلكترونية
هذا اللي اسمه
مؤشر لقياس أداء الحكومات الإلكترونية في البلدان
إي جي دي آي
هذا طبعًا ينشر من الأمم المتحدة
وبدأ تقريبًا من 2001
بدأ كمعيار و 2003 أعتقد كان أول
تصنيف صدر
وبدايته كانت مع انتشار الانترنت
لما طلع الانترنت
بدأت الأمم المتحدة بالتفكير بهذا المفهوم
وهذا كان موجود في وثيقة الرؤية صح؟
وهذا اللي كان موجود في وثيقة الرؤية
وطبعًا في ثلاثة عناصر رئيسية
والفكرة من خلال هذا المؤشر أنه يحاول يربط
أكثر من جانب
هو صحيح اسمه تطور الحكومة الإلكترونية
لكن هو ما يقيس الحكومة الإلكترونية
الثلث فقط يقيس الحكومة الإلكترونية
والثلثين يقيسون شيء ثاني وبتكلم عنها
الثلث الأول الحكومة الإلكترونية
أو يسمونه أو إس آي الخدمات الحكومية الإلكترونية
وهذا طبعًا الخدمات المعروفة الموجودة اليوم
سواءً في الصحة وفي التعليم وخدمات الأفراد
وخدمات البلديات
وهذا الحقيقة في عليه تركيز كبير
ونتابع مع الزملاء بالجهات الحكومية
ومربوط بالمؤشرات الأخرى بالشكل المناسب
الثلث الثّاني؟
الثلث الثّاني يتعلق بالبنية التحتية
والفكرة هنا هم ليش حطوا البنية التحتية خدمات الاتصالات؟
لأنه يقول:
بدونها ما تقدر تسويه
بالضّبط، أنت لو عندك مشاكل في المناطق البعيدة
لو عندك مشاكل في الاتصال
أو حتى بالقدرة على تحمل التكاليف
إنك أنت حتى لو الخدمة موجودة
الناس ما تقدر تحصل عليها لأي سبب
فبذلك لا، راح يعطيك نتيجة قليل وعندك فيها تحدي
فبذلك الثلث يقيس البنية التحتية
حتى يضمن عندك البنية التحتية المثالية
والثّالث: هو يتعلق برأس المال البشري
وأيضًا الفكرة هنا تتعلق بالأميّة
والقدرة على التواصل
مع الخدمات الرّقمية والقراءة والكتابة
ومستوى التّعلم، وبذلك الفكرة يقول:
إذا هو ما هو متعلم، بذلك قد يواجه صعوبة
أنه يتعامل مع الخدمات الإلكترونية
يمكن نحن ولله الحمد بالسعودية ما نشعر فيها
بس كثير من الدول عندهم هذا التحدي
أنه ما يستطيع أنه يتفاعل معها بالشكل المطلوب
العام الماضي 2022 حقّقنا المرتبة واحد وثلاثين
مقارنة مع المرتبة ثلاثة وأربعين في عام 2020
وطبعًا النتيجة المحقّقة هي أفضل نتيجة تاريخية
حقّقتها السعودية، كانت أفضل نتيجة أعتقد في 2014
كانت ستة وثلاثين
والآن الحمدلله نحن في المسار المرتفع
ولا يزال الطموح كبير
تسألني تقول: والله هل نحن فعلًا واحد وثلاثين
من 192 دولة؟
أقول لك: بلا شك نحن أفضل من واحد وثلاثين
وذكرت بعض النماذج قبل قليل
و هذا اللي ثبت بالمؤشر الآخر
اللي هو مؤشر نضج الحكومة الرّقمية اللي هو جي تي أم آي
من البنك الدولي
ما يقيس 192 دولة، ولكن يقيس 198 دولة
حتى أخذ دول من خارج أعضاء الأمم المتحدة
السعودية ولله الحمد الثّالث على العالم
وهنا لما أتكلم عن توافرية الخدمة
توافرية الخدمة أثبتت في نضج الحكومة الرّقمية
الصادر من مجموعة البنك الدولي
أن السعودية متميزة جدًّا
وسبقنا الدنمارك، وسبقنا إستونيا، وسبقنا أمريكا
وسبقنا المملكة المتحدة وكندا
ودول أخرى كثيرة لما وضعنا النسيج بشكل كامل
وورينا أنه الخدمات والاستخدام من هذه الخدمات
ورضا المستفيدين منها بالشكل المطلوب
الأول مهم
والثّاني أيضًا مهم
نحن لا نزال نتابع الأول والثّاني وقد هنا يكون
في معايير وهنا في معايير
طبعًا المعايير في نضج الحكومة الرّقمية
تختلف شوي أو تختلف كثيرًا
عن تطوّر الحكومة الإلكترونية
مين الأول والثّاني عفوًا في هذا المؤشر؟
الأول كوريا الجنوبية، والثّاني أعتقد أنه البرازيل
البرازيل؟
أعتقد أنه البرازيل
أيش لقيتوا عندهم ما هو عندنا؟
ليش هؤلاء الاثنين تفوقوا علينا؟
البرازيل، طبعًا النتائج مقاربة جدًّا
نحن 97% وكسور قريبة جدًّا الفرق ما هو بالكبير
البرازيل متميزة أيضًا بتوافرية الخدمة
وحالتها فيما يتعلق بتوفير الخدمات مشابهة
كوريا الجنوبية قد يكون عندهم حوكمة أفضل
نحن تحدثنا قبل قليل عن حوكمة المنصّات
والجوانب اللي نحتاج نركّز فيها
كوريا الجنوبية والدنمارك عندهم هذا التمييز
ونحتاج أن نصل له بالشكل المطلوب
ولكن نحن عندنا خدمات أفضل
أنا ذكرت لك قبل قليل على سبيل المثال خدمات البلدية
خدمات البلدية ترى ما هي موجودة هناك
لكنها موجودة في السعودية
بلا شك هذه الدول عندها دروس مستفادة كثير
ممكن نتعلم منها
ولكن أيضًا نحن عندنا تميز في الخدمات
يمكن بشكل أفضل من العديد من النواحي
في مؤشر ثالث سولفنا عليه قبل التصوير
اللي هو المؤشر
الياباني؟
في جامعة وسيدا
جامعة وسيدا وطبعًا يعجبني جامعة وسيدا
ليش؟
أنا بعض الأحيان أحب
أطلع من المنظمات الدولية، لها اعتباراتها الخاصة
ولها بعض الجوانب اللي تحتاج عناية مختلفة
لما يجي لك كذا إن جي أو لحاله وقاعد يفصل
وعنده إرث وعنده المعرفة
هي جامعة وسيدا أيضًا
بس جامعة وسيدا طبعًا ما يقيس كل الدول
يقيس أفضل الدول المتقدمة في المجال الرّقمي
أعتقد أنه يقيس ستين أو سبعين دولة
والسعودية أيضًا أفضل نتيجة أخذناها
في المؤشر العام الماضي
أعتقد خمسة وعشرين
مرتبة السعودية خمسة وعشرين
مقارنة مع أعتقد اثنين وخمسين أو ثلاثة وخمسين
في عام 2020 فهذا أيضًا في تقدم
على مستوى المنطقة الصادر من الإسكوا
اللي هو الخدمات الإلكترونية والنّقالة
الحمدلله السعودية ما بين ثمانية عشر ثمانية عشر دولة
على مستوى المنطقة
أتكلم غرب آسيا وشمال أفريقيا
الدول العربية تحديدًا
السعودية الأفضل على مستوى العالم
فنحن في نُضج الحكومة الرّقمية من البنك الدولي
الأفضل على مستوى المنطقة
والثّالث على العالم
وأيضًا الإسكوا أكّد أن السعودية هي الأفضل
على مستوى المنطقة
أتذكر سولفت مع مجموعة أصدقاء
على موضوع مهدّدات وتحديات المرحلة
نحن نتكلم على اندفاع كبير وتناغم سريع
باتجاه رقمنة كل الخدمات
كل الأعمال
شفنا إيجابياتها في جائحة كورونا
أيش الجانب المظلم أو التهديدات اللي ممكن
تواجه رحلة التّحول الرّقمي في السعودية؟
والله طبعًا قد يكون هي تحدي أو مخاطر
وبنفس الوقت فرص
يمكن لو أذكر منها
بذكر يمكن جانبين أو ثلاثة جوانب
الجانب الأول: هو ضرورة خلق القيمة داخل السعودية
ويكون عندنا التلطين المطلوب
اليوم نحن ذكرنا عشرين مليار
تصرفها الحكومة على قطاع الاتصالات وتقنية المعلومات
طيب كم من العشرين مليار هذا مستورد؟
68%
الثلثين مستوردة؟
بالضّبط، فاليوم عندك فرصة كبيرة إنك توطن
وطبعًا هذا للمتخصصين في المجال
ما قد يبدو مفاجئ
نحن نعرف إننا نشتري رخص ونشتري المعدات
وكثير من الخدمات الاحترافية قد تجي من خارج السعودية
بس هذا يمثّل فرصة بنفس الوقت
وهذا بالمناسبة اللي نعمل عليه
اليوم في منظومة الاتصالات
منظومة الاتصالات اليوم لا هيئة الاتصالات
والحكومة الرّقمية
نحن نشوف العرض ونشوف الطلب
عندنا صندوق خاص للإقراض
اللي هو البرنامج الوطني لتنمية تقنية المعلومات
عندنا أيضًا برامج تدريب نعطي التدريب المطلوب
وعندنا مركز كود
فهي زي معدات كذا اللي تحاول تشتغل مع بعض
حتى إنها تحل هذا الموضوع
وعندنا مبادرة في الحكومة الرّقمية
على المصدر المفتوح تحديدًا
وهذه مبادرة مهمة جدًّا
حتى نضمن أنه يكون عندنا استخدام
للتقنيات الوطنية والتقنيات المحلية
وسوينا مستودع للبرمجيات
اليوم عندك تطبيق المصدر المفتوح
تبغى الجهات الحكومية تستفيد منه
تقدر ترفعه على المستودع
وجهة أخرى تأخذ نفس مصدر الرمز وتشغله
وهذا التوطين اللي نحتاجه بالشكل المطلوب
وأيضًا نشوف استثمار الحقيقة من الشركات
اليوم شفنا، علي بابا موجود وأوركل موجودة
وتقدم خدمات سحابية إن شاء الله أيضًا قريبًا
راح نشوف قوقل وراح نشوف مايكروسوفت
أيضًا نشوف استثمار وحضور أيضًا داخل السعودية
فبإذن الله تعالى أنه خليني أقول:
هذه الاعتمادية وممكن نسميها انكشاف راح تقل
ونحن عندنا مستهدفات واضحة ليس الحكومة الرّقمية فقط
ولكن على مستوى المنظومة إنها تقل بالشكل الكبير
والجانب الثّاني طبعًا الاستدامة
مهم أن يكون عندك استدامة
أنت تبدأ مشروع مهم التشغيل يكون مستقر
ولا يكون عندك أي تحدي فيه من كل الجوانب
أيضًا حتى من جانب القدرات
نحتاج قيادات
نحتاج مبرمجين
ونحتاج مصممين
ونحتاج مدراء نظام ومشرفين
نحن بحاجة الحقيقة للكوادر بشكل كبير
وهم الحقيقة اللي بيعطونا النجاح بالشكل المطلوب
وأنا متفائل أنه صحيح هي مخاطر
ولكن عندنا الخطط اللازمة بإذن الله
لمعالجتها وبالذات إنها فرص
بالنسبة لفرص لخلق قيادات
فرص لاستثمارات
وخلق نماذج تجارية مثالية بإذن الله
هو الخطر السيبراني أو خطر الهجمات
اللي ممكن تضعف الشبكة أو تخترقها أو تدمر
كثير من المكتسبات فيها، أيش التعامل؟
كيف نتلافاها أو نتعامل معه؟
نحن طبعًا بلا شك
يمكن الزملاء في الهيئة الوطنية السيبراني
عندهم عمل كبير على هذا الجانب
وسيكون من الصعب جدًّا لأي أحد أن يقول:
ما في خطر سيبراني
فطالما إنه عندك خدمات إلكترونية هناك خطر سيبراني
ولكن السعودية الحمدلله عندها
مستوى الصمود عالي جدًّا في هذا الجانب
وبالمناسبة السعودية الثّانية عالميًا في مؤشر
الأمن السيبراني اللي صادر من الـآي تي يو
وهذا يؤكد أنه الحمدلله العمل اللي يقومون فيه الزملاء
في الهيئة الوطنية للأمن السيبراني
بس زي ما أنتم تشترطون تعال قدم علي
عشان أعطيك ترخيص تساوي منصّة
هل تشترطون عليه أنه يجيب تأكيدات أو ضمانات
من هيئة الأمن السيبراني ولا خلص منكم يروح لهم؟
وشلون التكامل بينكم وبينهم؟
الزملاء في الهيئة الوطنية للأمن السيبراني
عندهم المعايير الأساسية للأمن السيبراني
وعندهم أيضًا معايير متخصصة
مثلًا زي العمل عن بعد
ومنصات التواصل الاجتماعي وغيره
نحن دائمًا أي جهة تعمل معنا
سواءً كل النماذج الثّلاثة اللي ذكرناهم قبل شوي
سواءً شركات أو جهات حكومية أو غيره
نؤكد على أهمية الالتزام بهذه الضوابط
وطبعًا الزملاء بالأمن السيبراني لا يكتفون فقط
بوضع الضوابط
ولكن يتابعون الامتثال
يروحون للجهات الحكومية ويتابعون امتثالها
ويتأكدون إن شاء الله عندنا العمل هذا بشكل مثالي
طبعًا اليوم
الذهاب إلى تقنيات جديدة يزيد الانكشاف
اليوم قد يكون مستوى السيطرة عندنا
في الفضاء الرّقمي وصل لمرحلة متقدمة جدًّا
بس أنت اليوم قاعد تشوف مثلًا
الذكاء الاصطناعي كيف أنه يتطور
قاعد تشوف والله تقنية سلسلة الكتل
كيف أنه قاعد يتطور أو سلاسل الكتل
الذكاء الاصطناعي اليوم
نشوف الذكاء الاصطناعي التوليدي
وكيف أنه قاعد يغيّر من كثير من الجوانب
ليس فقط على قطاع التعليم
ولكن حتى على قطاعات أخرى
شاهدنا نماذج أنه الذكاء الاصطناعي يستطيع أن يبرمج نفسه
وليس فقط يبرمج من خلال شخص
فبذلك هذا يعطيك تحدّي ويحتاج تنظيم مختلف
ويحتاج امتثال مختلف
وهي مرحلة تطور مستمرة
نحتاج نتأكد إننا دائمًا جاهزين له
هل في عملكم مراعاة أو مسار للأشخاص
اللي ما عندهم نضج رقمي
نتكلم عن كبار سن
نتكلم على بعض أصحاب الإعاقات
اللي ما يقدرون يخدمون أنفسهم في المنصّات
هؤلاء اليوم قاعدين يعانون معاناة
يشعرون أنهم خارج الدائرة تمامًا
هم لا يستطيعون أن يخدمون أنفسهم
مضطرين يستعينون بالابن أو الابنة أو أحد قريب
أو في ناس يستغلون هذا الاحتياج
برسوم معينة، تعال أنا أنجزل لك خدمة معينة
هل في توجه لمركز أو مكان
للي ما يعرف يتعامل مع جوال ومنصّة
أبي أجي أشوف إنسان قدامي
يخلص مع خدمتي وأمشي أو يساعدني
ما شاء الله الوالدة الله يحفظها عندي
الظاهر ثلاثة ألف رقم سري لأبشر حقها
كل شوي يتغير لأنها تنساه ثم تطلب
وكل غداء جمعة حيجي واحد من إخواني يحاول يساعدها
ولا ألومهم هذا بالنسبة لهم نقلة جديدة تمامًا
فهذه الشريحة أيش الشيء اللي يقدم لهم خلال هالمرحلة؟
عشان ما نكون نسيناهم
نحن طبعًا الشمولية أحد أبرز الأهداف اللي عندنا
واليوم جزء من المعايير اللي نتابعها
على المنصّات والمواقع
بعض الخصائص والمميزات اللي تساعد هذه الفئة
وطبعًا احتياجاتهم مختلفة
كبير السن غير الصم غير البكم
والكل له احتياجات والكل تعطى مزايا مختلفة على الموقع
بحيث إنك كيف تتعامل مع الخدمات
سواءً في القراءة أو حتى الصوت
إذا كان في تسجيل صوتي
وتستطيع إنك تتعامل معه بالشكل المطلوب
ولكن لا نزال مقصّرين
أيضًا هذه أحد المناطق اللي نحتاج نعمل فيها
خلال الفترة الجاية
وعندنا إن شاء الله برنامج قريبًا بيطلق
فقط لهذه الفئة
اللي قد إنها تحتاج دعم ولن تكون فقط من الحكومة الرّقمية
أيضًا مع زملاءنا في وزارة الموارد البشرية
والشؤون الاجتماعية
حتى يكون في لها التركيز المطلوب
سواءً كان تقديم المزايا والخصائص
للقدرة على التفاعل مع المنصّة الرّقمية
أو القناة الرّقمية
أو حتى توفير دعم من خلال مثلًا مركز اتصال أو خلافه
من جوانب اللي يساعد هذه الفئة لدعمها بالشكل المطلوب
فهذه في البال، موجودة عندكم؟
بلا شك
ممتاز، ياليت والله لإنهم فعليًا
لا يجب أن يظلموا في هالرحلة التّحولية
بلا شك
أنا ودّي أختم معك أبو صبا، وأقول لك:
وين رايحين؟ أيش مشروعنا؟
أنت أول
تفضل اشرب الشاي
عشان تروق وتعطينا إجابة ختامية رهيبة
أنت أول محافظ لهيئة الحكومة الرّقمية
في التاريخ سيكتب أنه أبو صبا هو أول واحد
وبذلك وضعت لعمل سيأتي من بعدك ويبني عليه
وكما هي بقية الجهات الحكومية
أيش هو مشروعنا؟ أيش هو
الحلم الكبير في موضوع الحكومة الرّقمية؟
وين نبي نكون في 2030؟
اوصف لي تجربتي أنا يا عمر ولا ولدي وبنتي
في ذلك الوقت، أيش هو شكل الحكومة الرّقمية؟
ممتاز، وهذا سؤال مهم جدًّا نحو المستقبل
وأنا أبغى أقول: الوسائل تتغير
ولكن الأهداف يمكن ما تتغير بشكل كبير
الأهداف هي نفسها
كفاءة أفضل وإنتاجية وأيضًا تجربة
الوسائل تتطور مع التقنيات الجديدة ومع العمل الكبير
لما نتكلم عن التجربة
زي ما تكلمنا قبل شوي
نحن نبغى تركيزنا بشكل كبير على الحكومة الشاملة
توحيد التصاميم
تقليل المنصّات
كيف العمل يكون من خلال مكوّنات مشتركة؟
وأيضًا رحلات حياة مترابطة
لا يهم الجهة الحكومية
ولا يهم المنصّة كيف إنك أنت تأخذ التجربة المثالية
بالشكل المطلوب
الإنتاجية هي بلا شك التقنيات الناشئة
اليوم عندنا عملية تحوّل كبيرة باتجاه التقنيات الناشئة
نحن لا نرغب فقط يكون عندنا منصّات
نرغب تكون إنتاجيتنا أفضل
باستخدام أحدث التقنيات ولذلك وضعنا لها مؤشر خاص
وبرنامج خاص لمتابعتها
وأيضًا الكفاءة من خلال الشراكة مع القطاع الخاص
وتحديدًا في مسار المشتريات والاستثمار
ومشاركة القطاع الخاص نبغى كفاءتنا تكون أفضل
من خلال مشاركة القطاع الخاص
ومن خلال الاعتماد على الخدمات السحابية
ونحن بالمناسبة نستهدف في 2030 أنه 80%
من الخدمات الحكومية الرّقمية
تكون مستضافة على السحابات بحول الله تعالى
وهدفنا المرحلة في 2025 أنها تكون 50%
واليوم؟
اليوم تقريبًا نحن نحو 30% أو 35% ما بين هالرّقمين
فنحن نحتاج أنه نصل إن شاء الله إلى اعتمادية أكبر عليها
وبذلك يكون عندنا كفاءة
وتركيز على الأعمال الخاصة بالحكومة
ودائمًا نحن نؤكد على مركزية المستفيد
نحن اليوم تطلعات المواطن السعودي كبيرة جدًّا
والتطلعات هي التي تدفعنا إلى الإمام، بلا شك
وحريصين جدًّا على توفير أفضل الخدمات
وأفضل التجارب بحول الله تعالى خلال السنوات القادمة
كم رحلة حيكون عندنا؟ كم رحلة عمر؟
نحن أعتقد نبي نوصل نحو خمسة عشر رحلة
خمسة عشر رحلة تختصر
أهم الخدمات اللي أحتاجها كمستفيد؟
طبعًا سواءً كانت لأفراد ولا حتى لأعمال
وبذلك تعطيه الخدمة بالشكل المثالي
كم منصّة في 2030؟
أنا أعتقد بكون عندنا نوعين من المنصّات
منصات خدماتية
ومنصات معلوماتية
معلوماتية موقع عادي فيه أخبار
المنصّات الخدماتية بإذن الله تعالى لن تتجاوز 200 منصّة
وتشمل القطاعية وعلى حسب الاحتياج
الباقي راح يكون فقط خدماتية
وبالمناسبة المعلوماتية
وبالمناسبة عندنا اليوم خدمة مهمّة جدًّا
اللي هي خدمة بلاغ رقمي
وتساعدنا على الاستماع بالشكل المثالي للمستفدين
كيف أشارك؟
ثلاثة أنواع، وشلون تشارك؟
طبعًا من خلال مركز آمر للاتصال
أو من خلال منصّة (GOV.SA)
وهي ثلاثة أنواع رئيسية
النوع الأول إذا عندك شكوى
حاولت الحصول على استجابة
من الجهة مقدمة الخدمة بس ما في استجابة
تستطيع إنك تتواصل وتصعد الشكوى
هذا النوع الأول
النوع الثّاني إنك تبلغ على خدمة ورقية
تقول: والله الخدمة هذه عند الجهة الفلانية
المقدمة للخدمة لا تزال ورقية أو طلبوا مني
الحضور إلى الإدارة أو الجهة المسؤولة داخل هذا الجهاز
والنوع الثّالث
فيه خدمة رقميّة
ولكن عندك فكرة لتطويرها
تحس أنه والله أعتقد تصميمها ممكن يكون أفضل
تقليل عدد الخطوات
الاعتماد مثلًا على سمات حيوية، أعطنا اقتراحك
فاليوم ندعو الجميع الحقيقة على الاستفادة
من بلاغ رقمي ورفع كل الأفكار
ولا سمح الله أي شكاوي أو بلاغات نحتاج نتعامل معها
وهذا التواصل وهذه الشراكة
والمشاركة الإلكترونية المطلوبة الحقيقة مع كل المستفيدين
نحن المفروض في عام 2030
نكون ضمن أفضل خمسة دول
اليوم نحن ترتيبنا واحد وثلاثين صح في هذا المؤشر؟
واحد وثلاثين في هذا المؤشر
بس في مؤشر آخر نحن الثّالث
اللي هو نضج الحكومة الرّقمية
فيمدينا نصل؟
أنا أعتقد إن نحن وصلنا اليوم في نضج الحكومة الرّقمية
اللي هو صادر من البنك الدولي
في مؤشر تطور الحكومة الإلكترونية بلا شك
أعتقد أن فرصة قائمة بشكل كبير
أننا نكون بإذن الله من أفضل خمسة دول
خليني أختم وأقول:
أيش الفرق بين مقابلتنا الأولى في سبتمبر
كوكيل وزارة الماليّة ذلك الوقت
ومسؤول عن منصّة اعتماد
وبين مقابلتنا اليوم
مع معالي محافظ هيئة الحكومة الرّقمية؟
أنت ما خليتني أقول شيء عن وزارة الماليّة بالمناسبة
أي
وزارة الماليّة ما ننساهم
الزملاء يقومون ومستمرين بالقيام بعمل رائع جدًّا
معالي أبو فيصل جدعان
وفريقة في منظومة الماليّة
واعتماد اليوم يتطور بشكل كبير بالمناسبة
تحوّل إلى مركز نظم الموارد؟
المركز الوطني لنظم الموارد الحكومية
وهذا فريد يمكن ما بين حكومات حول العالم
وهذا المركز يساعد بشكل كبير
هذا الإي آر بي حقنا صح؟
هذا الإي آر بي واللي هو يدير الإيرادات
ويدير الرواتب ويدير أعمال كبيرة تخص الحكومة
اليوم اللي وصل على منصّة اعتماد
كعدد من حيث عدد المنافسات المطروحة
تقريبًا 850 ألف منافسة
اللي مطروح من بداية المنصّة في بداية 2018
نحن قريبين من مليون
فتشوف حجم الفرص اللي اليوم تقدمها
المنصّة للقطاع الخاص ومستوى الشفافية العالي
قلبك مع اعتماد ما زال؟
والله بالأكيد
أنا كنت في الدنمارك قبل أسابيع
والتقيت مع وزارة الماليّة
المسؤولين في وزارة الماليّة الدنماركية
الدنمارك عمر
أفضل دولة في المؤشر
الخاص بتطور الحكومة الإلكترونية من المملكة المتحدة
أفضل دولة
الحكومة الإلكترونية
اليوم في الدنمارك وكنا نتحدث عن عملية إعداد الميزانية
وتحديدًا في المناقشات كنت أسألهم:
وشلون تبدأون المناقشات مع الجهات
وتحددون التكاليف المطلوبة؟
اللي تبين كالتالي:
لا يوجد دورة رقميّة من الطرح إلى الشراء إلى الدفع
عند الدنمارك
كل جهة تعمل لوحدها
في بعض الجهات عندها خدمات رقميّة
بعض الجهات ما عندها، فلا تتوفر لديهم
لا يوجد لدى وزارة الماليّة هناك سجل
موحد للعقود والالتزامات
أنا سألته قلت: أول ما تبدأ تناقش
تبي تقول: وين العقود؟ وين السجل؟
حتى إني أستطيع أعرف التكاليف والالتزامات اللي عليك
لا يوجد يعتمد على المدخلات من الجهة الحكومية
وأيضًا لا يمكن الدفع بشكل مباشر من القطاع الخاص
اليوم نحن في منصّة اعتماد
بقيادة الزملاء المتميزين
حتى القطاع الخاص يرفع على المنصّة الفواتير
وهذا غير موجود في كثير من دول العالم المتقدم
اليوم القطاع الخاص يدخل على منصّة اعتماد
وهو اللي يقوم برفع الفواتير
فاليوم بلا شك في تميز كبير
بس نشيد فيها وعشان ما ننساهم
وما في شك لهم فضل كبير
بعملية التطوير وهم جزء من الحكومة الرّقمية
الفرق كبير طبعًا، نحن كنا نتكلم عن الماليّة العامة
اليوم كل القطاعات، سابقًا
الماليّة العامة هو تشغيل
اليوم تنظيم وإشراف وكل القطاعات
و اليوم يمكن عمل كبير على
المؤشرات الدولية بدعم الجميع
وهي رحلة مستمر
ويمكن اليوم ثاني لقاء معك
ولكن إن شاء الله بيكون معك لقاء ثالث قبل 2030
بإذن الله تعالى نسعد بك دائمًا أبو صبا
شكرًا على قبول الدعوة
ونستناك تساعدنا في إقناع باقي قيادات المنظومة
أنا متأكد أنه يسعدهم جدًّا
نتشرف فيهم ونتشرف بك
بإذن الله
شكرًا أبو صبا
الله يحفظك تسلم
شكرًا لكم
وشكرًا لفهدة القصيّر
في إعداد وإنتاج الحلقة
ياسر آل غانم في إدارة التصوير
ياسر كدشة مساعد الإضاءة
وفي تصوير الكواليس عبدالرحمن عبود
في تسجيل الصوت عبدالعزيز المزي
وفي الإخراج الفني مجد القرشي
وفي التحرير أنس الخليل
وفي الهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج
غيداء التميمي وأصيل بافرط
هذا بودكاست سقراط
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع